thank you
[Music]
yeah
my check my check
apologies little technical issues we
were like we got them resolved Brown
talk to me let's see how my levels are
sound see if I'm coming through all
right
oh man that watch what's going on with
seleuse loose Loop Gerald Maggie OG I've
seen the video I've seen the videos
going on slow Bay Area back from the
dead what's going on here early what's
going on brother good to see you I'll
get to see you next week that's right
slows and salad I appreciate you guys
dick I appreciate you Lydia Master it's
Timmy what's going on pop not too soon
time soon time
Chris 713 was going on salute salute web
Dave I see I'm gonna get you up in here
don't worry about it got a little
technical issue but now I was able to
resolve it I didn't even have to bother
attic I bought the attic all last night
bro he saved it you say [__] I sound
good but I sound like a Sega family that
is correct that is correct that is one
if you want to call me a favor you can
call me a sailor fan I'm a Sega kid I'm
a refugee I didn't have a home and and
then I found another car so that you
know they kind of look similar look
familiar
but that was that was when I was in my
Fanboy James definitely six slave what's
going on bro appreciate you man always
appreciate your um Tech stuff you sent
me much love you already know hands
could still enigmatic dreams was going a
big cloud what's going on bro it's a
little Fastback I'm seeing some classic
names in the chat let's go Necromancer
said what's up what is going on for rope
what's going on yeah we got a good one
we got weapons we're gonna get him up in
here have some fun we got some fun
topics yeah man he said yo you got the
place nah man I went there they sold out
bro I was so tight I wanted the um
and I wanted those Spider-Man Wings was
going Astro pirate king what's going on
Salute yeah I wanted the only thing they
had was control I'm like man so yeah I
might mess that but I'm gonna try some
other connections
ksati what's going on congratulations on
100 episodes brother congratulations
Parker Burris what's going on no doubt
little guy no Mario Kart actual parent
behave yourself anyway let me let me
move I'm running a little late let me go
get the man the myth the legend web Dave
up in here and uh yeah we got some fun
some good topics and uh you already know
this stuff has a little beefy [__] no
doubt beefy [__] is coming it's coming
yeah we got we got something cooking up
for that we're gonna see but anyway let
me get up
Attic in the crew and uh yeah we got
some fun today
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the flame still I'll be
running collecting them rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social nor my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and hell is be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rains you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was
[Music]
get back
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain uses a Target when
I'm in the range I was the hardest to
start regardless back when you with
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social lower
my CD but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but I ain't gonna hold you I
ain't heard a boy and you ain't gotta
say it I'm embarrassed for you I always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Voltron with gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell an Uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns uses the
target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
the yoga fire plane they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social
knowing my CD but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
thank you
detrimental to an elemental was an
avatar to an even though I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
cry Nido who cares if he flies you still
a mosquito you swear you ain't nothing
but really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if he really was that joke can't
ever still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord's day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a large day
radio
[Music]
all right so the bikes are hot though
the bikes are hot
and we was disclosing but we was
disclosing
ain't no more damn disclosing
we fixed this little thing right here
though stop with the damn beef emojis
y'all out of pocket
get the show start y'all already with
your with your messages
and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 315.
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
I'm extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got Final Fantasy games
coming to Xbox
single player game approach and Ratchet
and Clank PC hard drive performance to
discuss not like this gym
so we could get right into it I want to
introduce the Lord who's soothing voice
and informative interview style easily
qualifies them as one of our OG outbreak
Gamers whether it be as insightful
gaming interviews or passion for pop
culture all done with professionalism
high production values and vibrant
positivity
introducing the creating host of the
outbreak Gamers YouTube channel former
rock radio personality and panelists of
the breakfast with boom podcast
the Lord of Atari and vintage gaming
wrestling Aficionado and the only man to
interview Buff Bagwell and contain the
Motley Crew
live from Bourbon County Kentucky and
finally making his debut into the realm
of the Lords my man Lord Webb Dave how
we doing sir I'm doing great but with
that introduction I need to I need to
put some shades on me yeah that's how
you pulled up I like how you put when we
got hood web Dave y'all now you know the
pregame was lit yeah like see how you
coming through right now yeah yeah yeah
leave that first thing let me put that
that was her web day right there now we
had to burn me he had to say he came
through
I didn't my goodness thank you so much
for having me on today this
is going to be great great topics and
an amazing panel and I've been blessed
to interview each and every one of you
and on my web page uh for uh for YouTube
there is a section that has nothing but
the iron guards or all four interviews
are right there in a row or people can
check them out so easy to get to Great
Insight on some amazing men and again
thank you so much for having me here
today guys much love brother much
appreciated
listen we gotta we got a section yo life
is good life is good everything's been
good with you uh What uh games you've
been playing man
gosh um I've been playing Diablo 3.
yeah because right before four came out
they ran a big sale on three yep three
all the expansions and number two
um all for
like I mean I like 15 bucks so yeah I
jumped in playing that a little bit and
I'm still torn between four yeah
yeah I I'm thinking about getting four
and then I'm and then I still want to
get Street Fighter you know I got enough
uh put back to get one of the other four
is a departure of how
um one through three is played you know
because four is like uh on this and you
know something just happened that made
me really turn away from it but I'll
talk about it when it's my turn but yeah
no doubt no doubt just a heads up um
attic I saw YouTube getting some weird
little errors in about uh I don't know
if Checkers YouTube have an issue
because I'm seeing some viewers will
experience buffering like YouTube is it
yellow yeah yeah yeah but my connection
strength is from I just want to give you
a heads up that it's the first time I've
seen YouTube say this I mean
OBS telling me that YouTube got an issue
what's happened is most likely it went
yellow for a couple seconds and it's
glitched into that okay my stream's okay
most of the time it won't stay healthy
it won't come back all right so I got
the old notification so what's happening
is it went down and it and go back like
the the text glitch no doubt God that's
that tech support on Deck no doubt
anyway appreciate y'all doing that
webpage just real quick uh if it if you
start to see people complain yeah just
close out of um Discord because no doubt
no doubling look like the stream the rum
telling me we good they say nah you good
it's all good on I I know that I just
want to make sure no doubt he said oh
wait hold on I'm a kid saying now it's
happening you guys are freezing
sometimes all right we'll see yep it
happened on mine okay and then I had
Dave a little bit Dave broke up a little
bit yeah
ah I see YouTube don't do us like this
YouTube You're Gonna Do Me Like Showtime
to me last night Paul yeah the only
thing that I can do that I do to fix
that is I go to the bottom and uh I
click up on what task is running and I
just close everything you ain't using
right now yeah yeah yeah it might be one
of those give me one second just to make
sure I close out of Discord yeah machine
if you have steam popping up yeah
um
sorry y'all on the Fly professional
podcasting give me one second we fix it
now oh yeah it's going to be the whole
thing yeah exactly we want to get it
right we want to make sure we don't miss
anything
let's have to say just saying No Doubt
no doubt all right so we got that and
then hold on
yeah now everything else is kind of
kind of closing my side but it's yes
YouTube is not receiving enough video to
maintain smooth streaming as such video
viewers will experience buffering but
again you saying that's an old joint
no on my end it's here too yeah so no
basically stream status is poor yo I
mean what we could do you want me to try
to distinguish you did it
I don't think that's gonna help yeah
usually like once you close out of there
if it happens too much then we'll have
to debt it but I I don't
I usually just keep going and it just
corrects itself
I don't know let me let me let me
restore would you like me to hop off no
no let's try let's try something I'm
gonna back
out of the jump put a one in the chat
guys if it's buffering I want to see how
much of you it's affecting yeah let me
restart and then go back in there
two
yeah I've never seen that ever that's
why I was like it's happened to me a
couple times on that addict show 10 days
all right we're going we're gonna rock
we're gonna rock well hopefully
hopefully y'all they say a lot majority
people saying it's not buffering but
we'll we'll rock out see how we go all
right anyway
professional podcasting you already know
we got the Four Horsemen of gaming those
original Lords of the realm here at the
round table my co-host Nicole Mouse my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord attic of the attic show back to
back how we doing sir back to back
oh we got the spit
it's been a Rooney
she's crazy I've had about a week with
the steamed oh so it's a fun thing like
one thing I will say is I don't like how
big this thing is like this thing is
huge yeah yeah they're saying this ain't
no smell
again boys
this game here uh ethereum shift yeah
how am I supposed to pronounce that
stuff you got it all alterium shift I
said it oh my
I think that you
you some it's official people steam deck
makes you 10 smarter I have
to give away to these games
bro I was bad like child's like chill
this man bro he's like he's like
uh
ulterior shift is just pretty much a
it's like an old school Final Fantasy
game and what's cool is it actually lets
you pick what character you want the
main character to be
and what I like is
the other characters they're it they're
still in the game wow so you pick one of
them you're pretty much in like some
school scenario and the other people you
don't pick are still in the story but
they're doing different stuff when
you're doing stuff like one would just
disappear and then just show up randomly
like I I really like it I really like it
the uh the developers reached out to me
and they said you know we want to give
you guys a couple of uh codes to give
away
oh yeah yeah
I don't mind being
yeah you're a little low added you're
just a slight low yeah I'm right there
at the mic though I didn't say stick
your mouth in the mic
what I said is raise your levels it's
almost kind of like your bike like it's
um like it's picking up not picking up
the uh sure
just want to make sure I wish you sure
you check your windows over yeah make
sure he's sure or you should make sure
it's actually on the road I feel like
it's not on the right bike yeah it is on
the right mind all right so you just
turn it up a little bit just tell me
what's up I can make a dope commercial
for sure
people talking and they low are you sure
are you all right what about now all
right yeah
that's explosive but you're good yeah
yeah yeah there we go
you know
yeah it's a steam game so it's not a PC
game but like it does I don't know does
does your rock Ally work for steam game
yeah it was a joke yeah yeah so you you
guys have access to that and you know
it's it's not verified on Steam but it
works just fine on the steam deck so no
don't leave your bootleg copy yeah yeah
I mean usually usually smaller games
they haven't verified but verified
mostly means technically yes it means
that it runs but what it mostly means
also is that like UI is is set up so
that it works fine on the on the steam
deck because a lot of times it's the UI
issues for games where they don't like
resize like text and stuff like that so
it'd be super tiny
I have um I had they gave me three codes
but we have someone that does all our
time stamps and stuff and it's uh Jamie
likes these type of games so I'm gonna
give him the third code
yes stream says excellent collection now
yeah I told you it was right no doubt
anyway so that's been it sir yeah so I
put those in there and I will say that
it is a nice little thing to have what I
like is I could play a lot of these
smaller these smaller games on it like a
arterium shift I was playing z uh Xeno
Xeno nuts too it's pretty much like an
x-com
it's inspired game okay
so uh it's it's been a little fun time
we we PC masturbates that now you you
kind of you okay I've been playing my
Xbox more than that oh now you can play
Xbox one but you've been promoting this
crazy because I've been playing Persona
I've been playing Persona and I got like
almost 70 hours in Persona yeah and I'm
still not probably not even halfway
through the game yeah oh so you like
collecting book bags in that game though
they don't make me a glorified delivery
guy
they got other people to do that they
don't expect me to do they got other
people delivering and fluffing oh man
two different people
look at how we have you know behind the
scenes fluffing I don't understand
[Music]
that's automatic
back to you who's your favorite back to
YouTube on Persona uh they're they're
all miners my friend oh wow this is
crazy this is next anyway so look at the
chat try to catch me slacking
this is somewhere else but a good to see
that you're playing games and having fun
anyway
and that was wild that was why it's
weird to ask me what my favorite
walkthrough is on Persona
anyway and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo game who
lives for the single player selfish
experience oh that's right the doctor is
over his IPS during solve segments is
insane is right where it is right you
back up he like so I was back interrupt
yeah
yeah I was just agreeing that they're
correcting me in the chat thank you
thank you
and also the Sasha Davis the Lord of
clarity a lower patreon of the I am bake
PC Master races oh my man and returning
thankfully Lord sorry for now we doing
what's going on
happy to be back happy to be back first
off I just want to say thank you to
everybody everybody who reached out
um and DMS on the timeline to wish me
well so yeah uh right before the show
last week literally like 30 minutes
before the show uh the freaking the
kidney stone bug hit me again and I just
I killed over I think I called Cog maybe
like 10 minutes before show start like
Cog I can't do it yeah no Newsroom
there's no way you could have sat there
for that many oh no no it was impossible
it was true to the hospital that initial
pain is is Hospital pain like it's it's
not a game so um but yeah thank you to
everybody my brother for looking out for
me all my brothers here on the podcast
checking in on me King calling me every
single day and making sure he's like
he's like are you good I'm not your
brother not you yeah we had to get him
out of here so hard I've never prayed so
hard for another man's situation yeah
yeah because yeah because I explained to
the boys like I you know my doctor was
like so I got spoiled by the first time
I had this kidney stone because I got
rid of it in less than 24 hours right so
I'm like this is what it is how it goes
right so this time no it ain't happened
um I got it Sunday I expelled it like
Thursday evening
so and this was especially uh
serendipitous as Colin Moria I'd like to
say serendipitous because
um my doctor said okay I saw my doctor
on Tuesday and uh and he was like well
if by the time I see you again Friday
it's not out we don't have to do a
procedure I like the way exactly and I
will not
I would not belabor the uh the details
of what that procedure
Doctor Strange list says soft got his
blood sausage clogged I'm done
the more seeds I was clogged for sure
bro yeah so um but yeah thank you to all
of you for looking out all the well
wishes I appreciate it man I appreciate
it but I'm glad to be back uh and the
guys were surprised that I'm feeling as
good as I am anybody who's going through
a kidney stone knows that as soon as you
get rid of it you're like yeah let's go
I'm like oh he got the fresh cut he
looking right like energy is up it is
yeah but but again I I had wished that
this never happened to me again but
apparently so I have to take more even
more steps to hopefully break down the
ones that I still have in my system and
continue yeah and that's the thing
that's the changes that that's part of
the changes that I made the first time
yeah
um yeah but my doctor says salt would do
it way more than anything soda
um and again even good stuff see this is
the problem like I eat pretty healthily
um I used to have an omelet or an egg
scramble every day with uh with um
spinach spinach is a no-go really and
this is a no-go because in in excess
right and if your body is just
extracting too much what they call
oxalates from it that's what causes the
stones to form so anything that's
oxalate Rich can be detrimental to you
so that peanuts strawberries uh caffeine
that's how you know Popeye is really
messed up yes
I'm sorry I can't see what I'm drinking
this is this is a green juice this is
like a celery yeah we're gonna act like
that that's illegal
I'm glad that you're feeling better
brother yeah I'm glad to be back so um
unfortunately because I was in
excruciating pain I didn't get to play
much man I'm like I thought okay I have
a couple of days here maybe for so for
the first couple of days the pain was so
bad and the drugs I had was were not
very good
um I really didn't have much respite so
like I couldn't sleep so forget about
gaming so this morning I got up a little
bit earlier again tried to finish
Resident Evil 4 remake so I'm right at
the end and I'm still I still got to
finish that up so that's the the extent
of what uh what I've been playing no
doubt that bro back yeah of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
access gamer oh the prophet of Xbox
Swami King of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
whole the line movement ooh beloved Lord
King how we doing sir I'm doing terrible
today how are we how are we doing I'm
doing absolutely disgusting today you
know I called you you know what I call
with certain situations I I popped in
and I was otherwise occupied but I
popped in to see what was going on it
was beautiful though man you had a crowd
in there that was a beautiful thing he
did his thing but no I I love it um
everybody that came through on the
Twitter live stream
um like I told people before Kos combat
talk with the king
um the king play sessions they will all
be through uh live through uh Twitter
excuse me and it's uh because you have
to use these social medias to the extent
uh first and foremost I would like to
um give a shout out to everyone who hit
that cash app thanks uh you know and
then that was highly appreciated because
if you watch yesterday Showtime went to
bed
and my son came through with some
streaming joint that uh helped us all
you know I'm in the process of acting
Showtime to give me my seventy dollars
back
um and really wow wow they went to bed
it was like it was it was buffering they
had so many people that that wanted to
see the fight and it was saying like
when you went to Showtime itself it was
just like yo you know we experienced it
uh that had a global difficulties please
you know stand by whatever
anyway
um so but did get a chance to see it uh
and if people don't know what I'm
talking about I'm talking about Spence
versus Bud Crawford let's go I'm high on
Spence like I'm hiring on man Downs crab
season narrow Springs big fish
and yeah facts you know him yellow Easy
Entertainment and then at the same time
I like Bud I like Bud a lot and when bub
was in you know other divisions I like
Bud a lot but you know um liking
anything you got to pick who you like
you know you like you gotta pick you
know between your kids and you know I
picked Arrow Spence I don't care I still
pick expense today even though he got
obliterated I mean he got it's like
I've never seen anything like this in my
time where you take the two best in
right Vision the two best I mean Spence
went through and he broke people down
down and then you had Bud that did what
he did on his side and he came through
now Bud's questions was his opposition
see see opposition dictates how you
would do in direct competition right
because that's a measuring stick that
you use to say okay this guy did this
and triangle Theory never works this and
this is the reason why triangle Theory
never works a b c because and then you
know that stuff never really works
because you you know in theory like you
know Einstein did a bunch of theory but
in actuality these things have to happen
in order to prove that theory to be true
right so I uh Einstein's a theorist not
a um
[Laughter]
so what happened with Sean Porter or
whatever you know doesn't mean certain
things right man oh man I've never seen
a one-sided washing and if I did
Envision on one side of Washington it
was always in my my I'm listen I'm the
professional fan I didn't say that you
know I'm a professional analyst or
whatever and regardless of what I bet
with my heart then back money I ain't
crazy but like to see it happen I was
screaming for them to stop the fight in
round seven yeah yeah I was like yo stop
it um I don't see anything changing in a
rematch uh because it's what it was was
Bud outclassed him every level yes right
and to to further exacerbate the point
but never did the things that they said
he needed to do in order to win switch
Styles and stay elusive you know how to
deal with pressure
Bud Fort him Toe to Toe yeah from round
one and never switched from South Pole
yeah at all it's crazy eat him to the
punch he punched down on him and he
punched through him he was hitting him
with the stronger harder uh more
accurate shots and I'm gonna tell you
man it was like watching one of my kids
it was my stomach was bad
um you know I had a tear in my eye but
at the end of the day I'm not crying for
no multi-millionaire I mean he did get
paid he gonna be all right he gonna be
all right after he you know everybody's
asking me oh you know my girl asked me
oh wow he can sit there because we
watching a post-fight interview I had to
sit there and take that so first of all
your man baby yeah he wanted to do that
to Bud so I don't care I don't want
nobody to say oh I feel sorry for Smith
no because he wanted to do that to Bud
so Bud all Bud fans would have been
feeling that way oh for sure we wanted
Bud fans to feel that way so when it
happened to you oh you just gotta eat it
right so real man stood there he shook
his hand
and that's what a real man does so a lot
of people that got a chance to see a
fight you got a chance to see history
and you gotta you got a chance to see a
real man step up and you got a chance to
see a real man in Bud be a constant
professional these both of them was
constant professionals throughout this
whole uh uh production
he cashed that check he sat there and he
was answering those questions and you
could tell
he's going to deal with some stuff
eternally internally yeah I could so I
saw it through him yeah but externally
he was he was being who he's supposed to
be he showed his family he showed people
around the world what a true champion is
supposed to do because we had a fight
earlier with pitbull Crews was fighting
uh Cabrera and at the end of the fight
Cabrera walked out the ring you don't do
that win lose control you're standing
you take your medicine you have your
conversation you give the people what
they gave you and you walk out but
that's enough for combat talk yes had a
great time everybody that did show up
every Saturday at 10 p.m we going live
that's what MMA oh that's that's with
everything so you're gonna teach me what
a bare naked joke but that is not your
name that's not the name of the move oh
that's not it time but but y'all gonna
help me learn you know off the Rope
shout out to Justin gay G for winning
the title last night that head kick oh
yeah yeah
yeah he got slapped so both of them
slept each other they got a boat running
back right now I don't know I don't know
they're gonna run it back we'll see
we'll see you talking about that and
then uh fives in the building correctly
your rear naked choke
thank you
I don't know what show you watching
there's a lot of grappling and slappling
oh man anyway
King Washington cinematics
UFC Skinner match
yo um
let me yeah let me let me say what's up
I've been playing fortnite finally
finished that battle pass and I'm on to
the bonus battle pass right and um
we was on a police show yesterday yeah
shout out to spawn on me it was that was
so dope but after that
I jumped on fortnite and uh then I
jumped on fortnite last night because
I'm finishing up this battle passes out
I do want to play games
and they dropped the Terminator skin
last night and dudes that I that don't
even play it was like yo I think I might
have to get in there I was like wow what
happened and you know shout out to big
uh big fat Eli he was like yo they got
the skin bro and he's like yeah I think
I'm gonna have to join you like join in
come in the water spine my son you know
got a chance to watch me play yesterday
and then I gave him a couple of tips on
streaming because he wants to be a
streamer I gave him a couple of tips but
you know he streams on Playstation so I
was like your stream might not be too
tough
yeah because we need to fill out that
paperwork to become uh a content creator
on uh on Epic
well it's not just that it gives us a
code where like uh we get like
commission anytime someone uses it it's
pretty much like a standard affiliate
code but we can do that interesting we
do need that account to be able to host
our own stuff on fortnite though like we
can build the realm and have people come
through and there's IOP stuff we're
gonna have a hundred that's right I
forgot I keep forgetting fortnite is
happening yeah what I would like to do
is you know start playing
doing community uh strains with other
communities yeah
we got to do that and we got to build up
these tournaments because we need fight
night Fridays back yes um
so playing that playing Diablo 4 I had
to take a break from it okay because I
had my character my character remember
when I was struggling to do that and
everybody already got their character
Max at 80 or whatever yeah my character
was still at 40 so I got my character to
45 so I go to log in it was like yeah
man
um season started uh yes and you can't
use them you can't use the dude you
can't thank you for no one second and um
I said excuse you like what the hell are
you talking about yeah if you want to uh
partake in all the new stuff the new
stuff you're gonna make a new character
New Guy and um start again from ground
one yep I said on God you in the bushes
you in the bushes I don't know who over
there thank you for saying that thank
you for saying that crazy like yeah and
they do this every season
you you've you've thrown your game away
like you you literally told somebody
that don't have all the time in the
world that my time don't matter
but your character can exist in The
Ether over here play around over here in
the bushes with the broken yep
excuse me so I gotta be a super try hard
I have to be multiple character grinder
a farmer
to to exist in the new battle pass yeah
yo this is the reason why fortnite
Stomps you dudes in the heck
no matter how far how long ago you've
been away you come in you jump into the
new season with all your skins and all
your stuff everything is a fresh game
fresh time that you play it I'm so sick
and tired of somebody taking a formula
and trying to flip it and I know what uh
uh Activision Blizzard would try to say
well your character be too op going into
the new season well what you do is you
make that op character on a higher tier
but your tier system goes up to a
certain number and you are not putting
in the work to make that happen so but
so your thought processes make all the
time that you've done irrelevant I think
that's ignorant I think it's stupid and
you turn a fan into a foe that's not
game of the year that's game of the
garbage oh man I don't care about it I
was talking about it
you know did you know this why I went
yesterday when I was on um where we was
on spawn on me yeah and I said
um that uh Starfield was going up
against tears of the kingdom and
Spider-Man and I didn't Diablo yeah
that's why yeah exactly because Diablo's
in the garbage but that's all I've been
playing and I ain't been playing Diablo
there you have it the kid got spoke like
oh I didn't buy it now
don't buy it it's a great game we just
again apparently they they they do that
but I understand King's Point because
it's like it's kind of like generating
fake engagement and it's like just let
me play with the character I want to
play oh oh I got to close something I
got to say something I gotta say
something I gotta say something yes
please go go because yesterday was a day
of stand-up men okay right and for Tega
plays it's a stand-up dude
um you know some stuff happened in the
background and uh and I reached out to
him like yo whoop-de-woo and hit me back
and he was like
um yesterday you know he made situations
right if anybody saw that stream with
Spence and Bud that was all courtesy of
for Tango plays a little tinga Blaze hit
the PayPal
um and he hit the PayPal
really well you know absolutely so you
got a patronage yeah you got to salute
the guy who who's a stand-up dude and I
support all the videos and stuff that he
puts out if you don't know who vatanga
plays is go check it out he's the king
of salt mines and um his videos is very
funny you know his videos is up there
with with uh guys videos to me I think
their videos is really good and I think
they dope for the community so
definitely go check it out and for Tega
yo shout out to you before being a real
G and a stand-up man of your word that's
what's up bro no doubt attic you're
gonna say something before I go no okay
cool
great content please all I ask you to do
is hit that like button and if you so
kindly love to share this out share it
all let somebody else see it let
somebody else have fun stop holding it
to yourself
you guys are remembered I like the the
uh the podcast when you walk in I
wouldn't have to hold people hostage oh
my God addict doesn't hold nobody has
their daddy
and if you get a thousand likes Atticus
spin around in the chair some more
[Laughter]
talking about what's been going on
Starfield and the latest little montages
and stuff go check that out obviously
check out the last word he bought this
talk got Travis talking that Destiny
made my man Patty Cakes up in the
building Destiny PVP and the upcoming
showcase and then for me you're still a
little bit Tekken eight closed beta
still going on now open up to Xbox and
steam so getting the cross play on there
um real quick solve um rock Ally gang
I'm late to RIS and I'm just learning
about RIS on the Ally and I'm not gonna
hold you soft I feel like I was playing
Diablo 4 with my new character because
I'm a necromancer now so they don't yeah
they do I'll be raising the little
skeletons out here I'm a sorcerer
into the ground everyone is rebelling
and they just like don't play oh so
that's the Beast yeah they Nerf sorcerer
to the ground
that character because I just started
doing anything with them yeah see it
don't wait until the because they go of
course correct I guess in October for
everyone's complaining like it's it's
really pitchforks in the street on
Diablo with them but necromant y'all
like that yeah salute The Necromancer
you notice that you can solo with him
right yes you can rock out with him you
got your goons you got your dual stuff
but anyway so that was that and then um
oh that's what I tell you so all right
yes so basically I played Diablo 4 and
um I used to do like 720
with that bro I'm doing it it really
adds an extra level of detail I feel
right it's supposed to give like an out
it outlines and sharpenses yes I'm
really loving like a lot of our games
are looking way better and I tried it on
some older games too um Attica be proud
of me fired up on Xbox Chimera squad on
the Ally oh a tool tip for y'all for the
dudes and this is for man if one away in
the checkers one away call me one time
about this if you're having problems
with offline in the Ally two things Xbox
app there's a setting make sure the app
is offline Windows store go to the
library go to exciting make sure that's
offline but another problem I was having
is any of them uh just for you to um at
it because you got to steam that any of
them 2K Games them games is owned by 2K
always got this launcher that want to
pop up after you launch the game and
then a lot of it requires you to be
online for this launcher to go through
so what I would highly advised put a
shortcut on your desktop that's it put a
shortcut when you install the game put
the shortcut on your desktop just when
you have no internet connection just hit
the what you call it the shortcut it'll
bypass that because I couldn't play
Chimera Squad midnight so because of
this stupid pop-up that when I was
playing you know outside of a wireless
connection so anyway that's all I had to
say go check that out that's been it for
me so if you want to get the super chats
or I gotta I'll show you pay the bills
that we got subscribed
um for some stuff yeah let me do soup
challenge okay super chats okay we got
first off let's welcome
the newest member to the realm Lord
bronze web Dave thank you sir I
appreciate you brother ah salute I know
that guy I know that guy too
then we have himanshu yadav with the 100
Rupees Indian rupees shout out to you
thank you sir but destroyed the guy King
you said but be ducking but Bud made him
look like an amateur Bud proved he's two
to three levels above Spence hashtag
two-time Undisputed yeah that's why we
we fight the fights right because the
scenarios an hour ahead and we can
believe whatever we gonna believe but
this is why they fight the fights and
I'm man enough to tell you that he
wasn't fighting me
um because out of that money on me but
you know um I respect dispense and I was
I I thought something that bud had to
show me and Bud showed the world yeah he
showed up that was his moment I want
everybody to realize you witnessed
history yes witness uh
um a dominant performance when you
needed it like he needed yeah to have
that that night and he ain't and to be
able to do it that's a great one that's
a great one it's crazy yeah I agree so
every question before we move on real
quick is so you don't see Spence having
necessarily done anything wrong he just
got outclassed
he's been out of the ring for 18 months
no excuses that's your business you
could afford somebody before then you
can afford somebody when blood Ford
avenesian you could afford somebody you
didn't you decided to be outside of the
Ring work on yourself he has a new
nutritionist that could have been a
factor because he looked like his
punches didn't have any power right
um his timing was off he was lunging in
with shots all Bud was doing was
catching him and pitching the moment
that he hit Bud was already sending yeah
see the Punch Coming yes as it's hitting
that means you're already in animation
yeah yeah bro
but but timing was on point Bud was
stepping in with a power jab and the
reason why he's in Southport because his
right hand is his power hand so
everybody's thinking he's just hitting
him with a regular jab no really his
regular jab is like a straight right
hand he's crazy stepping into the shot
hitting him and when he's hitting him
the moment he hit some with that jab
it's already turning he's not looking
for a return on shot he didn't care for
return on shot he's hitting him and then
he's punching straight down because
Finch was ducking yeah so every time it
happened Spence was off leverage butt
had all leverage and he had full talk on
every shot I'm surprised Spence lasted
that long yeah straight so hard just to
stay in
will they come in the Xbox now do you
know did you know that the critically
acclaimed MMO ff14 has a free trial and
includes all expansions including storm
blood up to level 60 with no
restrictions on play time yeah addict uh
let us know that yesterday actually so
that's awesome no doubt
there you go
um right let me give you let me let me
blow that up for you
okay rise of Detroit bread friend okay
oh yeah so apparently apparently a
certain game is coming out tomorrow that
we were that yes that I haven't gotten
uh an email indicating that we can put
our coverage back up all the certain
games yeah the certain games a certain
game yes I forgot about that yes yeah
we can't talk about just yet but uh
apparently apparently continue
um then we got the 500 with the I can't
I don't know what that says I'm sorry
but with the 500 yen uh donation from
across the pond I love this but but Xbox
has no fans in Japan hey guys hey what's
up appreciate you that's free from Japan
for real for real oh that's what's up
let me see if I can get a translation on
this name yeah that's awesome
I think I seen that name in the chat he
was like now the stream is good I'm in
Japan I'm like oh okay we really good at
this
let me see translate yes
doubt translate to something I can
understand
yeah that's the next one facts continue
then we have net watch ten dollar Super
Chat King a year and a half ago I told
you that bud with dog walk spends you
called me crazy
with the buck up yo um respect to you oh
I hope you bet a lot of money I didn't
see you in the Stream last night
I can't I can't tell but I can see you
here today so everybody can talk after
the fact there before the fact but what
I did was put my chest out there and I
don't remember what you said a year ago
but I remember what I said yesterday
today and tomorrow expense I still have
spins but God bless good luck with that
I hope you made money off of that with
your uh foreseeable knowledge
people better people better enjoy those
emotes because I had to redo all of them
yes yes he did a lot of work with me
you was back to back on her yeah
it was more like back to back back to
back back there you don't realize how
many emails we have till you have to
reset them all and do it all again shout
out to graphic godsister
Lord bronze shout out to the Lord's King
I was thinking Terence Crawford may be
the best fighter I've seen the book's
still being written but where do you
rank him all time at this point well old
time is something that has to be said
after he's done I would like to see him
fight boots because I think Bud could
stay at 147 for a little bit longer even
though he'd look like he yeah
so I think I think the the glamor
division is going to be the 154 division
you have Danny Garcia you have Keith
Thurman that'll probably move up there
you know um I would like to see Bud
versus Keith Thurman
um but I I don't see with that
performance
I don't really see who beats him I want
to know who's built to beat him because
we didn't know who was built to beat Roy
you know and Target came out of no place
so let's see what's up you know doubt
continue appreciate it down to Josh
dealing with our combat talk yeah four
guys sorry you got it was the fight of
the generation week we would have to
remind us to not talk mention it so
anyway it just showed me that I never
want to hear King talk about me fighting
anybody
they might do good
oh wait first Cog now YouTube is buff
two hashtag beefy oh man beefy jokes
there we go here we go and we got the
man who got them horns remember for 32
months Lord bronze I enjoyed watching
Bud give Spence Jr a boxing lesson with
the King on Twitter slash X last night
we need more big boxing matches no
shelter for taking place up in there he
said Phil spender getting games back to
back
no doubt definitely some inspiration
there you was one of those that made
that up pop of attic safe yes yes sir
then we got Robert Kelly Two Dollars to
protest so y'all Mike's a joysticks damn
man oh geez that's different oh you're
nasty sir
we got a heart get Chinese five dollar
Super Chat good to see you backstop
thank you brother appreciate that hope
everything is good now welcome to the
realm web Dave salute shout out
absolutely shout out to him for almost
dying taking a Hot Chip yeah salute he
survived oh he did it yes yeah yeah
he's good he was he was smiling and
laughing I was like yo stop smiling
laughing I said it's gonna stop fighting
your stomach when that milk wear out
he's like
yo then he disappeared off camera
our Target was fine for 10 minutes but
then he drank the milk went completely
downhill oh man anything for 10 minutes
and drank that milk and that the the
chip didn't defeat him that milk
defeated
there you go Robert Kelly glad you got
joystick to help with the stone side
whoa
I
sure two
Jason came over with the ex-wife
yo y'all have your own little story
lines with this this situation
continue
then we have darn thread with the 56
cases damn someone's been drinking too
much Advanced GG oh yeah by the way cold
oh yeah Lord Thirty use cold iron Lord
Thirty go to Advantage you get 30 off is
up right now Goldie I'm putting the link
in there stay focused stay focused man
was focused
it is then we got Cipher pole 92 five
pound Super Chat shout out to Jim Ryan
and his PS5 servers for sabotaging
King's combat talk and to Bud for
channeling his inner Cog hitting Spence
with some beefy shots
there we got Hollywood rules five
dollars to be chat happy Sunday my NYC
and West Virginia cousins welcome back
sir thank you sir shout out to the king
for a great combat talk Phil Corleone
taking Japan by force boss moves
salute we have akw five pound Super Chat
thank you Lord for the support on
Twitter sharing the love for me and my
family thanks yes absolutely absolutely
brother shout out to them all Mama akw
yes yes uh Jay Rembert five dollars we
chat shout out to King for that stream
and make sure to burn kids moves Xbox
card with gasoline
um coming for smooth again I gotta say
this right it's okay for uh somebody to
have an opinion is to be objective and
we have a thousand people in here we
only have 400 likes to fit that but um
I'm always gonna snap on my my brother I
always got pitches but you should never
you should never jump out of pocket when
I got pictures of you and your
underwears
[Music]
22 situation Xbox will not be letting
nobody do nothing and nobody over here
so you won't have to stay level-headed
and get back in line if you're not gonna
get back in line I'm gonna have to get
out of line show them
leave that boy low he got his own
opinion this way yeah remember Green
Lantern I could see yourself stupid
there we go zip David it's two dollars
stupid chat you want beef you can't have
little beef oh wait
hilarious
then we have easy Kenta two dollars
better get oh no it's Alex about Diablo
4. he was right yeah he did go on a ring
the chat was bad at him when he came in
here but there's some things we're
seeing you know the law just wasn't too
happy but I still love the game and I'm
playing the malignant season thing and I
just had to make a new character so
shout out to Necromancer though I'm
having fun
there we go just bring it three dollar
Super Chat seasons and gaming is us
paying to have a second job thanks
then we have Homeless Bird two dollars
the uh two dollars addict Dr Takami is
my waifu stay away oh I don't know
what's going on I don't know what's
going on there so much
of age okay all right it's actually kind
of weird that she's messing around with
high schoolers but you know we'll go
into that like but she she is of age
it's messy good to you then we have Dark
Wolf five dollars Super Chat have you
guys ever played Skies of Arcadia of
course yes it was originally on the
Dreamcast and to me it was as good as
Final Fantasy yep only got one of them
and we got Fonz gaming phone number for
26 months Lord bronze Lord fawns walked
my oldest daughter down the aisle and
partied my butt off last night's little
brother Saloon live though and I'm here
to support my Bros have a great show
shout out to you well Circle yes
we got hard to find member for 26 months
Lord bronze assalamu alaikum my brothers
I only dropped my member chat when we
get a full house I love y'all his name
is Bud Crawford by the way glad you're
good soft thank you brother appreciate
it no doubt yeah we learned about button
everyone learned remember I learned that
everybody's a fan all of us yeah
no one's during right at the moment
that's what you want people now we're
getting super chats after the fact but
baby I'm on board
then we got JD game of five dollar Super
Chat oh boy FF on Xbox
we will get to that topic all I see are
salty tea is pretty Tanga I hope you
minding all that salt dark Phil out here
Marching for us
JD game of course
balance and objective of all the realm
000 people man hit that like that like
button will be saving man
we're saving the wild endangered Spence
[Laughter]
Destiny plus outriders plus Monster
Hunter equals Remnant too oh yeah
shout out to Travis
they are raving about this thing I just
can't I got Diablo I got that's I got
too many yeah yeah sorry bro
John Wolfe two dollar Super Chat was
going to send this earlier but my SSD
too slow we will get to that topic we'll
get to that topic then we have Robert
killing two dollars Super Chat so Lord
cockamido what's your what's your waifu
and Persona 5. I have not moving on
yeah we have Echelon seven with the ten
dollar Super Chat peace to the Lord's
God bless your health self thank you
brother appreciate that thank you love
that appreciate you love love then we
got Danny passion of
here just for a laugh anyone playing
Revenant too yeah we try to try to get
our hands on that but yeah it's a lot of
games and we have some Jitsu Sage 27
months Lord gold Activision's Revenue in
their in their fiscal year 23 second
quarter this year would have contributed
an extra 47 boost on Microsoft's fiscal
year 23 Q4 Revenue increase over the
same quarter a year prior that's massive
yeah yeah there's a reason a lot of
money a lot of money last one on Remnant
2 you kind of up to three people oh God
I thought it was gonna be four for a
second that would have been cool
that's us playing can solve no play okay
you don't play with us I wanted to play
a single player yeah yeah of course of
course
I need Microsoft to go ahead and hit the
ex One More Time Square back in bed with
us baby and after that I need them to
get the main squeeze Sega baby
are we good we are caught up all right
right finally we got a very patient
person very patient with two people two
people extremely patient and we got
waiting right now so look let's get to
it um gotta pay the bills a little bit
and uh you know set some light a little
bit on that Lords of gaming.net go check
us out to that long that time of the
month y'all we we've been blessed man
really tremendous team tremendous
writers you know we usually give out
these Awards you know for the month and
uh competition is always strong it's
always strong for these kind of things
so yes now it's time to celebrate one
particular scribe you know in the month
of July with above and beyond he has
some great sort of necromancer news um
iodine Chronicle updates
um a Clash of Heroes review that was was
really dope so the latest winner move
the Lord dizzy log net scribe of the
month goes to see you Nick Chris Jones
playing it together no doubt our brother
right now could not be here but he uh
sent something for us to listen to
what's going on everybody it's your boy
Chris Jones aka the Michael Jordan login
AKA Lieutenant Chris of the hold the
line movement right behind General King
I just want to say thank you to
everybody that voted for me once again
for scribe of the month for the month of
July
um I couldn't do it without the great
editors that we do have we have a great
team
at lordsofgaming.net and you know the
iron Lords podcast always out here
in the streets getting those big
interviews doing big things on YouTube
supporting us as well as we support them
one big happy family at Lord's gaming I
want to bestow some words onto people if
there's anything you can strive to be or
strive to have it's the people and
talking skills of Lord Cognito the
confidence of King David the
intelligence of Lord Sovereign and the
never give up attitude of Lord addict
we're one big team always looking for
more people to uh join Lords of gaming
so check out the website make sure you
apply there the biggest and best
Independent News
Tech media gaming all that good stuff
and uh truly it's the Golden Age of
gaming play what you love love what you
play
salute
good I'm paying Target smack up the Jets
oh man yeah he's talking crazy oh man
Aaron Rodgers said it's on okay
yeah
absolutely absolutely because Lord Chris
you know I'm CNC unit in the building
and we got one more award that we gotta
we like to present from uh this is in
honor of our brother R.I.P dizzy you
know what I'm saying what we got here we
wanted to nurture Talent you know at
launchgaming.net and give proper credit
to the unsung heroes on the editorial
team that does their thing this is an OG
this is the first who's been here from
the very beginning with me and dizzy on
the site and you know we we was building
this thing and we wanted to you know
kind of stress quality in the English
language everyone solve we have this
discussion you know so about the English
language and how it needs to be utilized
properly properly yes deep respected and
not only this Lord helping us and he's
so proficient he's always doing this
while he's serving this country you know
serving our country the Air Force proud
to have him as a good friend of mine
back in capacity or whatever basis we
get him because I know his his schedule
is so crazy he also does you know his
improved social media take getting
people recruitment you know Hardware
reviews and the thing that I like that
I'm proud of him is that he always does
fun things in the team like from an
award standpoint or just to bring people
together as a community to actually do
something as a writing team like that to
me is super dope so we proudly present
long overdue by the way Loretta of the
Lord dizzy lognet editor of the month to
reic Mr Josh Reddick how we doing sir
doing very good [__] thanks for that
intro I think it's been six years since
last time I appeared on IOP I believe I
was here for episode three bro you went
episode three as Lord Frost like you
were there when like this you do with
this chat had two people in it and it
was it was usually us
that consisted of that chat to make bro
you was dead continue brother continue
yeah so I've been here uh I was one of
the founding members of Lords of gaming
and circus crossy of EIC uh once dizzy
had to take a step back for his health
stuff so uh rest in peace for him uh and
since then I worked as EIC for about a
year and a half and now I work as the
senior reviews over there so all the
reviews coverage you see uh all of that
work that goes into that is overseen by
me I laid out the standards of that for
the websites uh and currently we're
doing a lot of work to get into Hardware
reviews so we have some contacts with HP
we've done sort of with hyperx and
really trying to break into the space
and uh give our voice voice to what we
feel some of the best hardware out there
both on the laptop side and the monitor
side on the headset side in addition to
keeping up with everything that comes
out which is a hassle and of itself in
the games there are much less ones like
destiny that Cog and I've been playing
together for a decade at this point
facts and so no it's uh great to be here
really happy to have you on and always
appreciate the support that you guys
give to Lords of gaming for the
community side and if anybody has any
interest in coming and writing for us
we're in the market floor do writers uh
if you even if you are not you know a
perfect writer when you come in I will
personally oversee oh yeah he gonna make
sure he gonna get you in shape
yeah yeah yes he will I have a question
and I've always wanted to ask you this
question uh you I've noticed that you're
a natural born leader did you uh have
that going into the army or did you
learn these techniques I mean Air Force
uh
the military I'm still messed up over
Spence
going into the military uh did you learn
these techniques and stuff like that
because I've noticed that you get morale
up and um and and I just want to give
you a flowers on that fact uh was you a
natural born leader or was you uh you
learned that stuff and techniques while
you were in the military or was it a
combination of the two yeah so I've been
in the Air Force for a little bit over
11 years now I'm an officer of a major
in the Air Force and I'm a physicist so
um exactly flying planes uh instead I do
work on uh development of laser weapons
your mouth get your writing up continue
no comment
I had to talk a little bit because we
people don't know we get busy over here
yeah well see this is the difference
between uh us and everybody else we got
somebody that could shoot you we really
got shooters
[Laughter]
uh next spots though I believe are
robots so those are fair games right so
but answer to your questions so I did
four years of ROTC uh that was all
leadership development and then over the
course of 11 years I've had really great
ventures in the military kind of
teaching me uh ways to I've always been
a direct person uh I get that from uh I
have three brothers and all of us are
always incredibly competitive competing
for literally everything and so over the
course of my military career it's
definitely been a matter of uh learning
different tactics to get people
motivated and to get the best out of
people so some people respond best to me
standing over them and saying charge
that hill and other people need a little
bit more persuasion so learning with the
deaf touch is necessary versus when the
uh more directive approach is necessary
uh is really the the key to to
leadership I found and really it's about
enabling the people and uh kind of
getting out of their way and letting
them lead themselves in a way that they
can take you further than you can push
them
no doubt lug drops brother
I can't believe it's been that long and
um you know I remember it was my first
Fan Fest I made you mentioned I'm gonna
say 2015 that was when I was dolo by
myself King of the Lord said I don't
think IOP existed yet and that's when I
met you and we were all all in that mall
you know try to hope for the chance to
get to the Xbox press conference and you
know just see E3 and end up being one of
the most magical Years brother we come a
long way I'm proud of your journey I'm
proud that you're still able to even
contribute on the team with all the
success that you have and we had to give
you your flowers brother Lord Josh ready
the man of many hats at lord.net and
answer to a couple questions in the chat
yes uh for the questions about aliens I
would like to refer you to Air Force
public relations
they said if you fought the aliens
yeah
as far as the hammer of dawn uh
have these space-based weapons are not
authorized via international law so no
Hammer of Dawn
and rods of God are not actually uh
directed energy weapons which is what we
call the combination of laser weapons
and high-powered microwave weapons uh
and said rods of God are about 10 meter
long tungsten rods that you drop from
space and when they hit uh critical
velocity on their way down the impact
that they can hit with is equivalent to
the load of a low yield nuclear weapon
wow
once again emphasize that weapons are
not authorized by international law
hahaha and there you have it we learned
a little bit more today Josh I
appreciate you brother congratulations
enjoy enjoy Sunday find out about your
boy Aaron Rodgers already know you you
looking into it and salute my guy Josh
hit me up hit me up on DM's job so I can
get you your your oh yeah Lady Lady Lady
Josh might need some things because
she's wearing those those get up in that
store yeah my girl's been checking out
Cog in that white T-shirt with the gold
on it and uh he shoves it off too good
so I gotta I gotta cut her off of her
yeah
in New York one of these days
I ain't gonna violate that line right
now
sure
Echelon seven remember for 30 months
Lord silver Bramble the Mountain King is
amazing and on Game Pass yes I heard
that was great I heard that was great
and we have Nintendo on the otaku
remember for two months Lord silver
Cog where's the topic for Pikmin four we
had an ff16. we had an FM 16 uh topic
but not a real game of the year
Contender your bias is showing again for
shame
why am I the person that comes up with
every person's topic like I have to
explain this to this man you not
attacking the right Lords we all pick
bro thank you every Lord picks a topic
and if you don't see your topic picked
then you need to holler at all the Lords
not just me like I'm the program
director everybody's thoughts nobody's
playing the switch bro
so ain't nobody checking for your title
no man don't do it like that don't do it
like that we gave you tears of the
Kingdom take your 480p behind and go sit
down oh don't do it like that
I see we don't have the important topic
about the Apple acquisition of Xbox our
brother kids move needs to change ff14
ain't enough actually I didn't let this
boy go man he's got a different opinion
that's it that's gonna hold his leg to
the fire anyway all right so all we got
to get him yes we're good all right
let's start
that's gonna be a debate and I don't
need to drop it today anyway now that we
have finally gotten back on point and
what the Lords have been playing and we
gotta shift our Focus back to our guest
do we have a guest today
Lord Webb Davis video game system
history his journey into radio and
content creation and of course what led
him to creating the informative outbreak
Gamers YouTube channel so Lord web Dave
let's start from the very beginning what
was some of the first video game systems
you had and what got you into gaming sir
well first video game system I had was
the Atari uh
600 when my father took me to get it uh
the day it came out so yeah that's how
old I am
baby OG talk real quick because this is
what OG I don't want to get to ask this
um no coleco vision people around you at
that time was it around you because I
was a coleco guy so I missed Atari a bit
and that's right yeah yeah so I just
wanted to know if you knew of anyone
that had it or you knew of it at the
time
and you want to uh didn't couldn't have
everything unfortunately you know you
know it's like yeah I was I was blessed
to get what I got and I enjoyed that
very much
um but no I definitely did hear even we
had one of those um I guess from like
Sears and Roebuck which was the plug
into the TV and it was a little device
that played pong like it was all at play
about the paddles right Hong and yes
yeah yeah
you know okay cool I'll go back to
monetary
you know
and and
growing up uh you know in middle school
and all that kind of thing we I used to
get those uh the uh in fact I still have
one sitting over there now
um the the Mattel uh handheld football
you know yeah
I love those things man I burned all
those things up and the Simon the all
different ones that came out I love
playing those kind of things it was just
you know that's just the kind of things
I like to play yeah I'm glad you
mentioned it so that was originally
handheld right oh yeah you know for free
I don't think those those get talked a
lot okay like those you know the joints
the one that you got in trouble what you
were when I stole the the what you
calling money the the electrical yeah
yeah yeah it was that was um game pocket
and watching yeah right so what was his
stuff it was though we had table tops we
had tabletop ones right and then there
were other handheld ones that I had one
I think I mentioned this uh today when
we when we sat down to talk I think the
alien attack or something like that that
I had then I try I'm actually trying to
get it back because I have it on eBay
um but yeah these the ones with the big
you know D batteries the C batteries and
it was but they had the arcade style
ones right which were the like the
Midway ones talking about the Midway
table top package tabletop Pac-Man
Frogger Miss Pac-Man they have Popeye I
had Popeye
um they had a bunch of different was
made from another one because they used
a mirror system yes at the bottom the
mirror yeah the mirror reflected to the
bottom yeah exactly I want to back you
up a second so I'm talking about the I
don't know Joyce that sometimes it was
clam shell yeah that was a gaming watch
that was gaming Nintendo oh that was the
yeah that was like Nintendo's earlier
offerings in gaming in a way with the
static images and they would move across
the screen or whatever they were black
and they yes yeah it just that was
Nintendo oh Nintendo got you because the
Nintendo got my butt wet yeah oh yeah
that's what you did thanks for that yeah
don't send the kids to the store with a
hundred dollars and he has to go past
electronic stuff
okay so what surprise at least I paid
half the bill she never looked at the
bill and this is the one time she won't
look at the building shout out to Huber
Davis yeah hubit you did it right yeah
yeah Huber didn't hold the line Hue be
goddamn folded like a deck of cards I
was like my mother asked me if it's
yours all you gotta do is say it's yours
and she was like is this yours he was
like no ma'am I was like this dude
foreign
with this classic these type of you know
handhelds and tabletop type stuff that
we used to play actually before the
console so this is really informative
continue sir yeah
I I used I used to love that kind of
stuff and then and then you know I
pretty much you know grew up through the
systems as as they came out you know got
into it enjoyed it you know there's
there was a lot of you know fun systems
I loved uh the NES uh you know would go
through the the pain of playing Zelda
and uh getting to almost the final boss
and and you leave the system on so that
you make sure that uh you know you put a
note on it don't touch don't bump no
almost every time somebody would bump it
and the little card should pop out
[Music]
the memory inside that Zelda and it had
an actual memory no one cartridge they
did that with and I was just like thank
God because we still had to remember
either the codes with Mega Man write
down the codes or that memory in the
Zelda which was huge or leave the game
on and and pray that nobody touched it
yeah yeah exactly and and I loved like
when you accidentally discovered
over the original Super Mario Brothers
warp zones yeah yeah like oh I jumped
out wait a minute what happened where am
I going what's going on I'll keep going
oh well I'm off the level what's going
on here Warp Zone what oh yeah you know
and then you find out how they worked a
little later but wow yeah I found out
those kind of memories are always fun
that was a huge deal this time so you
got that you got the NES and then from
the NES where do you kind of venture to
into the uh from the uh actually give me
some standouts from the NS and then
where do you eventually to the 16-bit do
you stay with SNES uh well I I I only I
went at that time I was able to afford a
little more always balling okay so well
okay
when you work for your dad early on you
know you're able to you know at a young
age you're able to you know to afford a
little more things with your with your
uh
um I guess the money that didn't have to
go anywhere else kind of thing so so
yeah yeah mom picks out uh goes shopping
get the clothes I go shopping and get
that's what it is
exactly not interrupt you again you just
trigger something that was the
conversation I used to have with my pops
because when the futiles he would take
me away from months like I don't care
about all we gonna get you what you want
and then he would be like gay games or
clothes he always had clothes always
lost
clothes never came up ever those poking
out the sneakers he said y'all can do
with this dog
because he was either toys or games in
fact I'm glad you said that that was one
of the conversations I used to have
about that continue with Dave
yeah but to be honest your clothes
didn't win
and until girls started taking on some
importance
like you know maybe I need to look a
little better than these old ready
clothes and look a little good for the
ladies middle school high school yeah so
but but before then it was it was it was
focused on games but yeah I played the
you know well I loved uh my Sega I had I
had one of those as well so I had both
so that was you know kind of Lucky but
you know I I loved loved loved playing
on the Sega Genesis
but yeah that was uh man that was it was
a lot of fun but then it's Super NES and
uh and then through and through on and
you know as as it got older as I got
older um I didn't
um
I
I had like the turbo FX 16. I'll just
move the CD-ROM and all that kind of
stuff as it came out yeah wait a second
it was rich bro stop playing yeah
this is a lot of brag toys
my dad had his own business
all right um all right now now we're
gonna peel back the layers of this onion
because yes these are things that people
he said pocket watch I mean I mean um
pocket gaming pocket he said the Mattel
handheld yes let me give you an idea of
what the Mattel hand hose was it was 20
something dollars each one
and you know 20 to 30 dollars you had
the football on the screen now he didn't
say just one he said a couple of these
things right yeah boom so you you win
side Sears and Robux citizen robot back
in the days when you walked in that door
talk to him your moms and them had that
Sears car he was on Deck like says was
that thing says was Best Buy if y'all if
y'all can yeah Sears was Best Buy that's
a great like member Fingerhut yes that's
a great about he had bread y'all put the
pocket watch you pocket watching right
there he acted like he ain't had bread
but continue he said Atari 2600 he said
now we ain't bothered with that coleco
but we went straight ahead we got the
Nintendo we went to Super Nintendo and
anything that came out but once he said
that turbo graphics and he said that
turbo Graphics 16 CD CD CD was 299 that
was back six dollars back in the day
looked like a taller boat it was an
accessory something yeah and when you
did get it people in the neighborhood
knows exactly what your wallet smelled
like and he better not say he had the
turbo Express oh then we really
foreign
all right links remember that not only
that but the Atari Links I had I had to
get the upgrade when it came back
I gotta shut your dad a gift I know
exactly what you're talking about
because the original links had it was
real big wide pause long and then they
came in a very Sleek so that means you
bought the links twice this man is
falling continue twice
so we did it because we did all this
what are you talking about yeah look
ahead sir so so I'm
I'm almost afraid to mention Neo Geo but
um
I did so so okay me and you before this
show okay hands up I got we gotta put
these gloves on because this is Bud
versus spin
conversations right here all right these
are three criteria that I could see if
me and you was on the same level because
all that stuff you talked about me and
you did that right there yes now there's
a couple of things that you know I can
ask about but I'm not gonna go there
that's too far
I'm gonna open book The the big mac and
cheese when it came to the Sega Genesis
the 32x and the Sega CD did you have
that stack
now they have four iterations of the Neo
Geo that had the arcade unit that was
the AVS that had the mvs with the home
unit they had the CD and then they had
the cd2 out of all of those what did you
have the first one okay so you had the
arcade unit arcade with the big
dictionary cartridges
they look like Encyclopedia Britannica
the one made for the home
yes so you had the MBS okay cool all
right so King got him over here a little
bit
he right there but I'm telling you what
his wallet is looking like this is a
powerful power in my circumference was
looking like this and me having a
conversation with you right now yeah
What car what cartridge was your first
cartridge with that neo-gels yeah
because it was like 200 I believe we're
going really pocket watch yeah we on
this yeah
well I had I actually bought like three
I think at the at the beginning oh my
this man had three meals
[Music]
it was crazy Baseball Stars now I'm 75
magician Lord
so okay so guys think about this that
Neo Geo cost 6.99 yes right so 700 700
off the rip right this back door they
threw me and saw out the store because
he was so broke and we knew we would
never afford it we would go to the store
to play the game the display model until
it closed and they kicked this out
because they knew he was never buying
yeah continue continue all right and
okay so each cartridge was from no less
than 199 right so you said uh as the
high end of Megs go that's the higher
the price go fast right so baseball
stars out of that was 249. a magician
Lord was 199. uh you said 1975 was 199
and you said Auto fight which was uh 249
right yeah oh you spent two G's Factory
up in this place right and um
how did you feel you forget the memory
cards
which allowed you to continue your save
data from home and in the arcade if I
remember well in your arcade yeah you
can take it to the arcade and plug it in
if you wanted yeah it really wasn't
saved data it was your high score oh
okay okay yeah so you was able to put
your name in there and you know because
you rocked in the house you go over
there and put it in pause
um
they yes when you got all that in the
house and this is all you right because
at this point in time you're you're
you're older you you had to be when I
got my Neo Geo I was working a job so I
had to be 17 18. so you had to be plug
probably your early 20s and um
so early 20s you're getting your checks
you you'll focus on video games heavy
because you had to be a real hardcore
dude it's a hardcore talk when you know
video games and and and drums so yeah
that was that was my big thing yeah okay
here we go we hooked it up to your TV
what was your thoughts your boss man
thoughts what's the boss because you
Boston right now right now
I mean like what was mine what was your
thoughts man I mean when I first got
into the house I was I was in my
underwear I had to sit down
by by the graphical Fidelity as well all
things you saw oh it was we played for
hours and hours and you know I had all
kinds of friends and new friends I bet
you had new friends
yeah okay all right yeah you know and it
was it was it was it was a lot of fun I
really enjoyed it
and now I wish I hadn't held on to it at
some point I let it go but um but yeah I
just um it was one of those things where
it's
I know I know there's a lot of things I
Wish I Still I wish I still have my my
Steel Battalion so you know the original
OG 40 buttons still Battalion Dave was
rich yeah he was rich as hell I remember
Steel Battalion and I went inside the
store and it was 275 dollars
and it came with pedals and shifters and
levers
[Laughter]
but my wife slash ex-wife she loved it
so much but you know
I guess so so you're getting all this
stuff yo Geo all right so since we're in
Pocket watching territory we gotta ask
more questions
um anything 32-bit era were you a 3DO
700 guy too or did you say no I never I
never picked up the 3D poker okay my
friends that had it but but I never I
don't know that when I saw like
the the Zelda on it was like
um
that's two that's two different ones so
you had the Philips CDI with the boys
it was weird Mario games and stuff like
that I got that crazy
um I got rid of it like two weeks later
but the video had the the arcade perfect
Street Super Street Fighter yes had a
way to Warrior yeah
did you have the Atari Jaguars yeah
because that's what I was going because
you were the Atari guy and Atari tried
to make a comeback with the Jaguar
during that era and they they ushered
quote unquote the 64-bit era was you
there did you put your Atari hat back on
for that
um
the I had the Jaguar if that's what
you're asking me yeah yeah yeah I had
the Jaguar I love that thing oh the way
you had to I really did you learn how to
drive did they have an attack though it
looked like a bidet did it look like a
bidet y'all remember yeah
controller on that too I really enjoyed
that because it felt great even though
it had the little the number button
thing where you could switch those
little pads out a little little cards
out depending on the game but I really I
like that controller was one of my
favorites until the until the Dreamcast
came out that was that's probably one of
my favorite controllers of all time as a
Dreamcast controller I love that thing
stream cats is still my favorite system
too overall all the ones I've had that's
uh it just um when I when I played the
you know the Soul Calibur and and you
had the option where you could set it on
the character and and it had this little
I guess motion capture yes one minute
two minute little scene it would just
sit and put it on it and watch it yeah
it's beautiful
yeah when they did the Carters in the
beginning
oh my God that was so beautiful oh man
this is this is this thing uh all these
initial launch games
um so you're the launch lineup because I
thought the Dreamcast had the greatest
launch lineup in video game history
facts um you know ready to rumble High
School
Crazy Taxi all these games
um you know and Pen try isolated
this is the first console that I walked
away with all 18 launch titles like day
one first okay first console ever Mr Lee
shout out to you Dr Mr Lee you ran my
pocket shout out to Boomstick he was in
the area
um yeah what what titles did you walk
away with on your initial Dreamcast
launch well it was
the um it was it was the blue Stinger um
and I believe
was the was the boxing came out at that
point yes
I believe really Rumble Okay so
yeah yeah and then there was one other
and I can't thank for the live me can't
think of which one it was I think he
might have said it uh a second ago
um
oh yeah it was it was the launch set
room Crazy Taxi Crazy Taxi was great
yeah yeah well and then and then that
one so yeah so that was that was the
four I guess that I had though yes yeah
I'm starting to love crazy day because
that Crazy Taxi had the
had the actual soundtrack The Originals
before they they pulled the song yeah
you know they pulled a couple of the
songs from uh yeah so which kind of
bummed me out I'll play later versions
where's the song at was it Sonic the
arcade uh Sonic Adventure as well yeah
that's right I forgot about this title
too yeah yeah I didn't get that right
away but it did pick it up later nice no
not cool I do want to back up one thing
because I never anything you're a fellow
I feel like I'm a lost tribe with this
I've never heard someone mention it I'm
you're a fellow Lynx guy like I never I
tried to get the whole I tried to get
the whole Hood to get one I would this
was me trying to fight Game Boy during
the era when Game Boy was so dominant
and I tried to get all the homies be
like look this is better this color it
got it would you say that California
game California games yeah California
remember we all put the links in and we
was all sitting in the room bro remember
we had the the daisy chain system link
there was a game called slime world
I mean the
the driving game uh for sure and uh but
honestly
at this point it's so long ago it's been
it's been a while since I had that yeah
and
but yeah I I'm you know I'm old
no I just appreciate I knew he was
official though because I appreciate the
links love because not many people know
about the Link's revision that you put
is you ported twice like I bought it
twice you know because I was a handheld
dude at that time yeah yeah because it
was my favorite
it was one of my favorite handhelds
period it was great and then when I had
this one I was like
I mean
and the fomo I guess I had to have that
one so yeah so I had to you know I think
I ended up selling the other one to a
friend so he enjoyed playing that for a
long time but yeah but yeah I had to
have the new and that's another system
that I wish I still had oh all the ROMs
bro so for now but uh you know yeah so
yeah shout out to um emulate the hell
out of that all the time oh yeah they
had a lot of arcade Perfect Games shout
out to um stash what I know about Road
blasters facts
yeah the side play one yeah I think it
was called Zito Checkered Flag remember
Checkers record flag yeah because it was
arcade perfect yes yeah and then um
Electro copper there's a couple other
blue Stingers right they had so much but
Atari was flexible now but I'm glad you
shot that so back up to Dreamcast where
he was at he rocked out
um you know you said it was one of your
favorite
um consoles uh DJI shared move
uh yes yeah yep nice yeah nice nice yeah
that you know and the the when two came
out it was you know wow yeah that was
that was next that was Next Level to me
uh oh yeah I really really enjoyed that
and really it was the you know this
story The the able to get into it and go
to different areas and you know then you
turn around you're like oh there's a
there's an arcade machine Let's just you
know and then you kind of you know you
could just do so many different things I
loved that about it you know the the you
know the digging in deep into the game I
mean obviously there's a great story to
it and it was like really cool well
fighting and stuff in it but
but there were so many other things you
could do you know like going to the you
know earn some money and go to the
machine and earn these really cool
little Collectibles which really did
nothing but it was there for you to do
so you might as well do it so you know
yes yeah yeah salute I was like yeah
like a real life you gotta do you go to
work you could get up you go to the
arcade day night cycle martial arts am2
it was phenomenal so then from there you
know Dreamcast this monster that is the
PlayStation comes in you know do you
also mess around with Nintendo a little
bit do you do PlayStation 64 what are
you doing
well
well I feel I feel like I've been a
chance like you know this guy has so
much money doesn't know what to do with
himself I
I swear to God it really wasn't in the
rich I just that's what I thought that
was my hobby so that's what I spent my
money on
maybe I'm gonna smoke there that rich oh
God
like myself I don't care Dave
you work in rarified air right because
okay it's cool to have a console right
and I'm not gonna let you downplay this
and I'm not gonna let you walk past this
era you was an alpha predator
like when you walk in a game store you
looked at dudes buying that game and
he's like yeah that's cute and um you
were you was an alpha predator use a big
dog fast like you came in big game
hunting you know they're getting games
hold on hold on they get games and you
picking up the CD of the games they got
and you got stuff that they won't get
all Feast so you was moving in a
different manner than certain
individuals looking at you and they
looked at you to see how dope Davis
what's what's Dave gonna do yeah you
didn't know the effect that you had on
people but I'm telling you Dave yes
Alpha Predators were different beasts
when they walked in stores picking up a
Neo Geo and talk about let me walk with
four games facts bro dudes looked at you
like
who is this who is that guy and he those
are the Jews that had the relationship
with the storm manager with the store as
soon as you walk in they calling you
Dave hey what's going on man and then
they put you on to exclusive content
peripherals and things that they know
only a baller would be interested so
King is right we not gonna lift you I
mean they could listen I guess I should
tell you this
the story okay let's go so a year before
the Nintendo 64 came out in the U.S it
came out in Japan and I had to have one
so I found a distributor that imported
and seven days after the launch in Japan
I had that and the um
um tomorrow 64. that was the first game
that came out there so I had that day
one I played it for like a whole year
okay so and then of course when the
American games came out a year later I
was like oh cool I'm gonna play and they
had this little piece of plastic inside
the N64 so that those cartridges
wouldn't fit facts so so you couldn't
put American games in in vice versa and
I was like what so I had to actually
order a special tool to take it apart
every game if you talk it sounds
language
yeah making cosmetic changes
with the paper clip within it with the
uh Playstation put the paper clip in
region unlocked
um with the famicom from the Super
Nintendo it was just the Plastics right
there what I did was take a little
soldering knife cut off the Plastics
right there throw the cartridges in
um I like the form factor of the super
famicom over the season
better look it was a better field the
Super Nintendo just looked it was it was
too much boxes
that had the big on top yeah
but
all right now now now we cooking I got a
question bro
um
do you have Game Boy at any time
you know I never really got into the to
those to the Game Boy my son did and he
had a lot of them okay so you had a son
remember yeah advanced was the first one
of those I bought okay okay all right
because I was going to the original Game
Boy and it had this little printer thing
it was like for Pokemon and you put it
on and you print out your little Pokemon
it it was
it looked like a register at the
supermarket and it'll go to
and it'll come out and he had the you
can give it out to people it was just
little obscure stuff like that as Gamers
and of our time that they were trying on
us like you think Nintendo did labo out
of the blue they've been doing crazy
stuff for forever like the capture
picture they had a camera on that thing
and everything
um what was the most obscure console
that you've purchased that is not
mainstream or well known but you had to
have it being that you had this uh
International connect
um yeah I mean because you know those
that was International yeah like he
moved away here
at the super International plug yo he's
the most Flex worthy dude we've had yeah
I go for it like that's why we had to
stop this show the traditional way
because the the talk that you're talking
this is very rarefied Ed this is very
Country Club this is very you know what
I mean it's a different Illuminati talk
yeah like so like I said King was that
for us and the fact both Named Dave is
just amazing to me
answer your King's question so what what
did you get some obscure stuff that just
like one percent of the gaming you know
public gets what did you get mine was
the Super graphic from NEC the
um the the the successor to the turbo
Duo yes what was what did you get that
was just super crazy that nobody got oh
just something small something that you
picked up
you know uh that's so that's so really
hard
hard to say I know I tried to get and
didn't get uh then this was not that
long ago I guess but the Apple made it
and made an actual console oh yeah and I
thought that would that would be cool to
get but I didn't I didn't get it so I
wasn't able to get one and then now
they're like super rare and super
expensive on eBay
um but yeah that they're really I mean
other than you know I guess probably the
Neo Geo because of the the expense was
probably the thing that people most were
like because it was just you know and I
and I know that I spent way too much
money on that you know I'm gonna
probably bought a car
but damn I had so much fun with that you
know and then like I said and it was the
the best part about it was I when I
ended up selling it I ended up selling
it at on eBay
uh for a guy who drove from Louisville
to come to Kentucky or to where I'm at
in Kentucky which is Owensboro so he
drove like two hours to pick it up and I
literally ended up making a profit on my
original purchase because he wanted it
that bad that's crazy yeah at the end so
I mean but you know I had it for like
three years but it was you know
[Music]
yeah absolutely this is we've broken
pocket watching history today yes you
know no one has you know as few people
that could even be in this this weight
class decision you know what I'm saying
in this conversation so salute to you on
that real quickly so can you just take
them to the uh I just got to get the
delivery real quick but uh soft can you
take uh Dave through the PlayStation
there I'm just I'm gonna be listening I
just gotta go get the door right quick
yeah so Dave tell me like you're all
right so you go from from all of these
consoles right now we're starting to get
more into the like the modern era right
right 96 97 everybody's excited about
PlayStation Sega Saturn
let's talk about that because we had we
had this conversation when we sat down
to talk
um you know
King and I you know we we held the line
when it came to to Sega you know and the
Saturn and uh obviously moving forward
into the Dreamcast what were your
feelings on that like what did you do
around then you stayed with Sega did you
go to PlayStation route as well did you
do all of that uh
I had both you had both and and whatever
he has had at the time so yeah that was
you know yeah
right you didn't engage in all that but
what was as far as the warring and
consult stuff yeah yeah what were your
thoughts on it you looked at it when you
looked at the PlayStation right and you
looked at what it was capable of doing
and you saw what the Saturn was doing
did did you did you feel like hey one is
better than the other or I'm enjoying
both of these for what they are and then
what were your favorites on both
consoles well I definitely enjoyed both
of them for what for
what they were because if somebody would
ever give crap about one of the other
and say well
come over and try this out if you don't
if you you're you're bashing something
you haven't tried come try it out I've
got it so come play it and then usually
they were like oh
you know and that's you know but for
like PlayStation when Resident Evil came
out I mean the original when a
PlayStation came out they had that demo
discussed in and they had like just a
dinosaur yes just walking around I
remember that like he was watching like
that's freaking cool you know that was
before Jurassic Park and all that stuff
and it was like what
that was that was so cool you know and
seeing seeing silly stuff like that but
then like Resident Evil when those dogs
jump through the glass that first time
it's a moment and I'm like you know I'm
a grown man I'm nothing scares me I was
like
dogs
yeah and that's and I loved it had to
play it all the way through so yeah yeah
those those kind of you know those kind
of games and Saturn would you know I
love the Daytona and stuff like that you
know I mean had even games like uh was
it the Clockwork night and final night
crazy
the one with the what was the one with
the bunny that you know I had a lot of
different weird games too yeah
it's a kind of like nice bunnies I guess
but but the one with the bunny it was a
side scroller
[Music]
you gotta understand like around this
time like now this is the time where
most of us like we started getting a
little more yeah it was dumping flash so
it's it's myself and Cog finally
starting to get some more disposable
income and be able to do some of the
things King is doing finally this time
so so that that's just it but in general
like your your story is so comparative
to Kings in that he was our dude when he
there was something new he had it first
he went out there he imported it you
know and it was it was that thing of
like oh wow can't believe he has this in
the house
um so that's just it man we just we we
giving you some crap but no no it's it's
it's all out of love because it it's all
good it is amazing because again it it's
funny because my next door neighbor when
I was growing up he had they had more
money than us and he had Atari 2600 5200
he got the 7 800. and I was always he
was a little he was a little rough
around the edges and I was smaller so
he'd like he he's like oh let's not play
Atari let's play wrestling and then I'm
like no let's I'm going home thanks
I'm good I'm not into getting beaten up
thank you yeah I'm good but um yeah it's
just that thing about having people with
the [__] with the shared experiences
right and especially Atari I know
attic's been so quiet
but this stuff is stuff that we love
because it's these moments like when you
talk about the dogs jumping out of the
window that's a moment I will never
forget yeah I remember I remember being
in my dorm room playing it in my and me
and my roommate are up and he's watching
me play he's like what the hell is this
that we're watching and we're under the
covers and we're like oh man here we go
and I'm walking down the hallway
oh man he's like he jumped out of his
bed I jump out of my bed and it's just
it's just moments like that that it
really is special and then so like I
said the PlayStation and and and the the
Saturn that was like sort of the
beginnings obviously of the 3D
generation and everything is different
now yeah no for real oh yeah yeah
um quick on the 3D which I think I
believe actually talked about this with
with all of you
um that um when the when I did have
um the uh the N64 and
and I had the model 3D and I think like
a year or so later they came out with
the
Donkey Kong uh 64.
um which I enjoyed playing uh my wife
now uh is uh she loved Donkey Kong
Country Side scroller from the Super NES
we had one two and three she would I
mean I she could beat the game better
than I could in fact I didn't think I
finished three to be honest with you
because she smoked me on that and I was
like you know what I'm done I've seen
anything so uh but but when we got the
the Donkey Kong 64 and she's she was so
excited because she loves Donkey Kong
and she played about a minute or two
and the camera another 3D gaming which
it made her nauseous it made her sick I
can't see it doesn't affect there by the
way Victoria was like oh no she in fact
she got the department if I was playing
games Modern games even games now you
know uh Elder ring stuff like that
she can't watch me play especially in a
big combat scene
even I'm like the camera's flying around
trying to you know trying to keep the
enemy in line I really screw
Ing and she was like no no no no no
she either go to her tablet or go in
another room because she just couldn't
she couldn't handle it and I understand
that but she's big on phone games what
she thinks are free but yes she has a
really she thinks he said when she
thinks
and suspended behind the scene
man PayPal says you bought this this and
this is this and that was that free game
you like yeah
this is great stuff again I appreciate
you educating our foolishness without
trying to just shake it oh no I love it
I'm trying to shame you
and you know why because
nobody ever's gonna give you this type
of love like this like I can give you
that love as a pair
yeah
it's it's it's different you know to be
the guy and to meet somebody that was
the guy you know like and then his name
is Dave
man I love the hell out of you like so
I'm gonna give you that ribbon because I
know what it was to when you you passed
the bread over because probably he
wasn't using a credit card at that time
because I wasn't really so it was just
like you know cash you throwing that
cash on the table you popping that
wallet out
a check write that check right then
check I love it I love it bro we can
talk gay stories this is amazing we can
talk again I want a chance because I
think you have like a unique history and
obviously you've interviewed both of us
I know so much about you now it's kind
of fun so like you know one thing I
thought was very interesting about your
history before the content creation and
gaming you were a rock radio station
director yeah so tell me about that
program director for the rock radio
station
well I when I had um I took a couple
steps back just to get us to where we
need to go absolutely
was um when I got a divorce from my
first wife
um which you know life happens and then
you know at the time it was devastated
but you know like a year later I'm like
this is the greatest thing that's ever
happened but you don't know that when
you're in the moment you know what I
mean so it's just it's one of those
things uh because we have a son together
uh my oldest and uh so so that was a
blessing that I couldn't get any other
way so and and absolutely so that part I
appreciate it but as as I you know got
older and I always you know growing up
like one of my favorite TV shows was
WKRP in Cincinnati and I just I was like
oh DJ so that's so cool you know and as
and as I got to be uh this was you know
in my 20s and recently divorced and I
had always uh I gone out on the you know
after that I was like you know I became
kind of uh uh I guess a technical term
would be a bar sled but you know uh so
he was out there
making new friends that kind of thing
yeah I didn't used to always be fat and
ugly but yeah
Dave was outside thanks a word for it so
so I used to have I used to I used to
have some fun and you had to get out
there and there was uh oh I I worked
with a couple of bands because I played
you know drums a lot and and uh you know
we do our own little thing but but there
was uh one uh uh that would come through
every month a bar band uh here locally
that would uh but they toured all over
the country and um but they were being
played you know kids and stuff like that
it wasn't
cover band is what we would call it yes
so um a lot of fun but
um at one point they lost their light
guy and they were like we need a Leica
and you are a drummer so you know how to
keep beating everything really good with
it so I was like all right cool so I
went on the road with them did the light
thing for a while had a blast because
they had a really nice slideshow uh for
for a quote-unquote bar band
um so much better than what they
deserved to have but it was really nice
a lot of fun to run you had a spotlight
guy it was it was pretty crazy so so
loved doing that and then one night we
were out of the gig and and somewhere in
Minnesota and that can't think of the
name of the graffitis maybe something
like that was the name of the club and
their DJ got sick that night and they
were like that house was it was a
Saturday night the place was gonna be
packed
know anybody you want you know I was
like you know sure I'll jump up there so
when the band broke I'd go up in the
booth and spun had a little fun and so
much so that at the end of the night
they were like
yeah hey you do what are you doing I'm
like no no I'm with the band I'm cool so
you know and then another like um six
seven months later uh another club
and the owner got in a fight the
nightmare there and
he fired him all the spot
and of course my my boss from the band
was like was like hey he can he can DJ
he's done it before so I'm like what
okay great so I got volunteered that
night so the long story short on that
within like a month he hired me because
he was actually closer to home it was
about an hour drive and he paid really
good money oh we like his in his club
and I was like you know what I need to
do this yeah so so I stepped in there
and um and the funny thing about him
which I'd never seen a borrower to do
this before it's at the end of the night
when they're counting money and trying
to get everybody out of the club you
know he would walk out on the floor and
I'm not lying or making this up with a
strapped around his shoulder
an Uzi oh wow it was loaded yeah exactly
yeah everybody time to go everybody his
last call was with the uzi last night
get everybody out that's what's up
everybody got out all those drunks and
then they drink out I'm not leaving and
I don't care about your life all right
last call guys wait wait wait wait
he got this rap he got the strap to get
like where was he positioned in the club
was he on stage was he was he moving
people out with the uzi like how was he
doing this no the the people that were
left like there was usually always like
10 or 15 at the end of the night after
during the last call and everybody out
blah blah blah blah he would come out of
his office with this we did where the
money was he'd come out with his gun and
he'd have a couple security guys with
him that would be kind of it was like a
details
to go
wait wait wait wait no this was the the
owner of the club okay but he would have
some of the security with him to make
sure because they were like okay you got
to go you gotta go and he was right
behind them with his with his Uzi you
know
also so so let's go we got to count some
money so did they like Circle the areas
of the ball like they would was it like
a you know what I mean like a path like
him with with the ghouls and like that's
how it was okay at that point there was
only you know stragglers at that point
that he'd have to they'd have to pull
the gun out on so otherwise
and and he but he really did it like
multiple times I mean it was there was
something
I'd said they'd clear everybody out and
they wouldn't have to do that but yeah
it was it was the club was no longer
there and there's like an hour drive
from here and it was called Yankee
Doodles yeah it was crazy they even they
but King you would like this that like
on Monday nights they actually had
um I guess
um
boxing but it wasn't it was it was it
was sanction boxing but it wasn't like
um it's like a Fight Night type thing
but they'd have it in the club it was
that big a club would set up the ring
and everything people sit around and get
stuff so yeah so you have club nights so
yeah yeah what um okay so that was like
he was probably the part of the chitlin
circuit this is what we call a chicken
and um what you would do is as a
promoter you book uh fights all around
like smaller towns and stuff like that
and those fights you know you're
bringing the referees and the judges and
stuff and those fights were either like
Regional or
um uh I forgot or Nationals regionals or
Nationals and they can have those
sanction fights or if it was fights that
were done on a professional level then
you would have a professional there that
can market and and and post those stuff
because there's a website that all that
information goes to so if he was doing
that stuff that stuff is really cool
because those are called Ballroom brawls
um those are really cool especially for
the town that brings Revenue to the town
it brings people you know from other
places in and um that's that's really
cool to have you know it's better than
having oiled up wet t-shirt night right
I mean that was that was probably
Thursday they had those too yeah yeah
this was still yeah noodles where the
fights was going on
what's up man yeah yeah this is yeah it
was like once some once a month they
would do that and they weren't even open
on Mondays but they would open special
just for this for these events that they
would do to bring in uh more people more
ground that was it was it was it was
pretty crazy and then and then from from
there I um you know I I guess
um
as I needed to to get better grounded in
finances you know I I did some some
other jobs and then I actually got a DJ
job working in the local nightclub which
is actually on my Facebook which is uh
which was called the warehouse nightclub
and that was a lot of fun and this was
where I met my current wife and uh we
had um we had uh we had a good time and
uh but but from there I actually
uh I did when I worked at that as a for
about two and a half years as a DJ Club
DJ
um like on Sundays there was a college
kdbc here uh Kentucky Wesleyan College
that um they had like a kind of an open
thing for like um because they had a a
local station because one of the things
they thought was broadcasting so you
could actually volunteer
to do radio stuff so I did that for
maybe a year year and a half nice you
know have a lot of fun doing it and then
I found out about a position and opened
up at a local radio station here a
Cromwell radio group I went in
auditioned for that was overnights for
about two weeks which if you know
overnights it's strictly uh
like nine o'clock at night until six
o'clock in the morning and it's like I
locked the building up and oh my God it
was so I hated that yeah and then they
had they got some new
um inner management and they decided
they were gonna do a crazy radio show
and wanted me to to be their producer
they called me producer Dave
for about six months and that was it was
fun but it got my foot
in the door learning all about the radio
business you know doing you know a lot
of people
you need stuff like syndicated radio Bob
and Tom and you know and and Howard
Stern and all that kind of stuff you
know they made a lot of money local
radio yeah yeah
but it's it was fun I made I made some
good money but it was it was it was so
much fun so much of a great learning
experience for me uh and then you know
then they ended up uh making me the
program director when they put a rock
station online and I did it for uh five
years nice as the program director and
of course afternoon drive and then with
those local stations the Chromo group
there was actually
seven stations inside of one building
and it was like different rooms were
different stations wow and people you
know in the old days it was one station
one call later one building you know
kind of thing but then consolidation
kind of like in gaming happened in radio
too and uh they would have all that kind
of stuff so I you know I do I do and you
could pre-record too which most people
you know thought it was a live DJ well I
do like the whole weekend show
for the hip-hop station oh and it was
classic hip-hop too which was awesome
and uh and I would and and but I but I
go in and you have like these little
bites and I would just pre-record
everything and have it all scheduled in
and because I knew what song was next so
I could I'd you know introduce the song
or and then we'd have marks and stuff to
where the computer would just fire it
off dope once in a blue moon you get a
call saying hey uh there's either dead
air or one song it's played 10 times in
a row
exactly yeah DJ that for for what I
loved doing it it was a lot of fun and
with that I got to you know interview
like
a lot of great Molly crew and and um I
mean just
um I just so many bands I can think of
that that I interviewed the REM and I
mean just so many different types of
bands that I got to go see I was like
200 Rock shows in the five years and a
lot of them we were like you know meter
greets and stuff and hangouts and stuff
it was so that was that was fun and that
was quote unquote the Glamorous part you
know was doing those but then
um like you said earlier when you go
into your local babbages became GameStop
yes and they knew you and their new
management was like he needs an
assistant manager hey would you like to
be our assistant manager oh well what
does it pay and I was like
but this pays better than the radius
facts let's go so I took that job and I
was there for 12 years working for
GameStop at our mall and loved that it
was a lot of fun but then in our and at
the time GameStop had
something like 3 000 Plus stores oh yeah
yeah a worldwide and ours on our store
was ranked like 700 so we had a good
ranking
um but it was in a mall in a mall that
was building negotiations weren't going
really well as far as the pay because
you know we were quote unquote an acre
store or for them uh you know even
though they had Sears and stuff like
that they they really wanted to have a
um you know to keep us there but it was
like that was like four thousand dollars
a month for rent where like we already
had in town two other strip mall stores
that those the rent for those were
twelve hundred dollars so after a while
even though we were a million dollar
store means we made over a million
dollars in profit right you know every
year that I was there
they decided that you know the income
the cost pull it compared to what you're
making what you're putting out here
closed it down and I did get an offer to
stay with the company
because what that is is okay so you you
said the rent was 4 000 right yeah all
right so the rent being 4 000 what you
have to do is make triple the amount of
what the rent is weekly
this is weekly because in that week you
have to factor in uh salaries and uh pay
wages because if you're management yeah
I guess you was on salary yeah
right so this is the way they mitigate
you making overtime so they put you on
salary and have you work using your
normal work hours for weekly is 40 hours
a week they probably had Dave working 60
to 80 hours but put them on salary so he
can't get the overtime pay all right so
yeah they gave him the title but gave
them extra work that didn't equate to a
title and then
um this is this is the business
practices of reason why babbages is out
of business and uh GameStop is going out
of business
um because of these business practices
and then you have at least three to four
employees and then you have dead time
where you have one employee working
where it's supposed to be a two employee
shift so that one one employee is
overworked and underpaid so that
employee is there then you have to fact
in a light bill and you have to factor
in the shipping and everything costs
because they do pay a cost to shipping
and everything to the store now if the
store is operating at a deficit which
they're not bringing them four to three
to four times weekly with their monthly
rent is then that that business is
looked at as a failed business and they
will close that business down
yeah no this is this yeah so they they
closed a lot of malls I'm sorry so and
that was just one on one of the traffic
blog now they did offer me
other manager stores but within the area
in fact
it was like seven different positions I
could have taken but they were all all
at least an hour drive or later away and
I was like no yeah so I took my
severance package it took a few months
off recouped uh and then um a friend of
mine was like you know work for US Bank
and was like you know
I want uh you'd probably be good at this
and uh and got through the interview and
and 10 years now with U.S bank and uh
work from home because of covet and they
permanently left us at home because they
said our productivity went up
so absolutely we did we're like I don't
have to go anywhere and just get about a
bed get to work so yeah so so that would
all in all you know it's one of those
things where like life takes you where
you go but over the course of a guess of
the
the last four or five years I met a
friend at U.S bank and me and him
decided we wanted to get into podcasting
because I kind of missed that kind of
radio part yeah yeah okay I'll take you
down that road I I missed I missed that
doing that so I thought well this kind
of be a way of doing a little bit like
like radio but to be on my terms kind of
thing I mean we still do some things
with that which is the uh Escape pod
um which I think we're gonna have an
interview actually coming up in a couple
of uh a couple of weeks uh with some
locals that that actually put out the
independent movies uh Blood Moon
pictures so we're gonna interview them
the creators of that and then talk to
them about their stuff yeah okay yes I
don't know what's going on with my
camera but it won't cut on now I turned
it off to take a phone call and I've
been sitting here for five minutes
wondering why
yeah it's got to be another app that's
open that's taking the resources but
continue Dave I'm sorry
what you do is you unplug it plug it
back in there you go reboot the computer
yeah oh goodness I'm just playing but uh
I guess so that's um that's kind of kind
of how that Journey came along and then
and then when you like said covert hit
and then I was like you know I'm sitting
it here at a house and I can listen to
her watch whatever I want to do I was
like well I you know love gaming they
talked about the new consoles coming out
with the you know with the series X and
the PlayStation 5 and I thought oh
that's kind of cool and I you know and I
and I listened I'll admit this I
listened to like IGN for a little bit
but after about
I don't know
a couple of weeks of that going they
just
they weren't talking
the gaming that I wanted to hear okay
you know they weren't it just wasn't
coming at me well I wasn't feeling it
because they were you know more bashing
by the Microsoft than they were just
talking about all kinds of games you
know to me I love games all kinds uh
I have my PlayStation 5 now and I love
it I prefer the Xbox ecosystem
system better but then I started finding
on on the Internet by looking around I
found Mr Boomstick ah here we go
[Music]
out of watching boom and then and loved
it and I reached out to him one day
a great show blah blah blah
and he's like
we got a good job one day I was like oh
okay so typical
yeah like like a couple of days later
hey what are you doing uh nothing we got
another show would you want to be honest
again sure sure did that then it was
like like a couple of weeks later and
he's like yo I got some breaking news
and I can't get anybody to jump on do
you want to Sure
boom step in talking we want to make you
a permanent panel member I was like
awesome I'm there so yeah they even
worked my my work talk to my boss so I
could I actually for breakfast with boom
I'll come in and I'll work until like 8
30 in the morning our time and then my
boss lets me take two or three hour
lunch oh that's the clock back in after
that and finish out the day yeah it's
not like my boss is super cool so I was
like but I worked it all out so there
you go and then just been able to grow
from there and did these great
interviews yes had all you wonderful
iron Lords on and which was it really it
it's uh I can't
when you get into an interview with
somebody that you a admire and that you
know you you love hearing the stories
about where they come from and what they
went through to get to where they're at
now to me it's I just enjoyed that so
much
and I feel blessed to be able to admit
over 71 interviews right now so
um you know that are in the can and more
to come
um and uh and I appreciate every single
one of you guys willing to come on work
with me I knew we worked at times and
stuff to to do it and I feel like you
know obviously I don't know you like you
know each other but I still feel like I
know you guys and I can call you a
friend and yeah you know and if I feel
like you know like when you guys reached
out to me you're like I'm like you want
me on your street
yeah you thought it was gonna happen you
were so cool man you're so cool I I
definitely want to you know give you
your your flowers too because again
obviously you've had us all on
individually which is very hard to do
because our schedule's crazy and he was
able to be you know able to pull that
off but you know one thing I really
respect is your professionalism you have
a very insightful interview style you
know you really kind of let the guess
shine you know what I'm saying you bring
a lot of positive energy so I guess for
my especially you is in reference to
interviewing and spotlighting you got so
many members of The Gaming Community
which you've had from all walks of life
you know why is that so important to you
well when like I said when I was when I
sit down and was was trying to watch
some
up then to listen to something
interesting to me which obviously gaming
is a passion it's a hobby and I enjoy
doing it along with playing music but
but that's really kind of where I'm at
now as
as I'm older I just enjoy playing games
I'm not great at games but I enjoy
playing them and to me that's really all
that matters you know if I get enjoyment
out of it there you go and then a lot of
times you make new friends like I have
now uh out of it you know so it's it's a
it's a it's a it's a great community and
and when you when you get them to know
something about somebody that you you
know I mean you know
King is a one of a kind yes he is and I
mean let's let's face it and everybody
benefits
from knowing more about King than all of
you to me seriously but but but to me
the more people that know about King and
what he brings to the table the
entertainment the the professionalism
the just you know those things
to me
I want to bring that out let more people
know it's basically why my channel is
there is to thank you
because you may tune in and watch
somebody that makes games you may too
many want somebody that
you know writes for games you may have
tuned in somebody that just plays East
sports or whatever or has her own
channel
you know and to me it's like it's all
one big it's the community of gaming
that's that's what connects us all is
gaming and uh I feel I feel about I said
I feel blessed to do it and the reason I
do it is because
I enjoyed hearing about your stories and
I figured there'd be other people that
would want to listen to it too no doubt
right about your story today because I'm
gonna tell you man like well thank you
it's it's a different swag that you have
and you're so humble you you know
you're very deceptive Dave
and um and I and I gotta let that be
known because you're so humble like yeah
you know somebody will look at you and
like yeah he played Nintendo here and
then no bro I had it all and um don't
you disrespect my gaming history because
you know somebody look at you and be
like oh you don't game as much
bro I I forgot more gaming than than you
can remember games I forgot more than
you've seen
um you was there for egm uh game pro uh
next gen magazine you was there for
getting the see the the tapes of e3 you
was there from all of that and you
participated in that in a manner that
some people can't say that they did that
like you know like party goers back in
the days was like man if you went to
Studio 54 yeah yeah
you that dude see that dude you said guy
so I don't want anybody to go to your
channel and don't know that you are an
alpha predator
dude like you the Apex go into your
jungle and you like it's Dave here bro
get that thing like you did it and you
did it on a level that dudes can't do it
like they can say now you know dudesflex
now is I got a PlayStation 2 your
PlayStation VR 2 and uh PlayStation 5
and Xbox series X and Series S and I
have a Nintendo switch and a Rog you say
I had a Neo Geo huh and I walked in the
store and I did that thing with all
these cartridges
you have to have a fortitude to go
inside the store to say let me get that
250 cartridge
and let me get the other one next to it
like it's a different dude so I gotta
respect you and salute you as an apex
predator as a dude that was inside you
the big the big homie that was the Big
Homie and that's I'm glad you said that
kid that's why I want to give Davis
flowers and you your flowers because I
see this rhetoric online with this game
of score stuff and it's like that's cute
but if you tallied every game we've
played and in the arcade where gamer
score didn't exist we'll literally lap
all these dudes and we can put all you
dudes together against us yeah you know
there's nothing you can do to compete
with our gaming history it's like you're
cool down in this pocket of time you're
cool God bless you do it that's where
you are right now in your life we're in
a different part of our life but what we
did to bridge this thing and the
community and to bring the culture
forward and all the games and that stuff
that we played and all the systems that
Webb Dave is talking about and King is
talking about if Gable score exists we
would be on the Mount Rushmore of this
so please don't come for us unless we
send for you because respect your elders
that's the problem I have this community
there's no respect for what comes before
you you have to respect the people who
paved the way that's why we got to give
flowers that's why we do I love podcasts
but continue thank you I want one more
thing right now sorry that's good and
and without the the old Gaming though
the pixels and the bong and all that
kind of stuff that we wouldn't be where
we are now factual no that's right it
all started there and it's just you know
you know and and if I say my fondest
memory of gaming would be like
in an arcade playing Killer Instinct for
the first time and finally learning how
to do the move where you where you have
Orchid pull off or top and the
character's eyes go back you know and
everybody's like how did you do that I'm
like I don't know but like I gotta try
and do it again you know so so that
that's the kind of memories that are
that are there forever and and I have
been because when I was at a you know
working for GameStop I was privileged to
be able to to do this paid for my own
dime but I was able to go to two e3s and
one of the e3s I went to was when they
debuted the uh Steel Battalion so they
had like 10 units there and I got to see
it firsthand that's why I was like I got
to have it because I saw it when it was
before everybody else did then before
IGN did the story on it and everything
so that was all the kind of things to
see you live forever yeah that's that
real talk like I didn't I never had that
like I never had distilled Battalion I'm
super envious to you right now you set
up you did the whole setup in the card
you put everything in the city and then
you hit the levels to get your your Mech
going fast that's crazy and it was it
was it was one and done yeah if you died
in the game you had to start all over
again and the eject Button had a clear
plastic plastic cover on it yeah
if you did it in time you could
you could keep progressing but if you
didn't do it in time it was start from
scratch so much fun so much fun I just
love the fact that again what resonates
with me again specifically is it was a
time when gaming was frowned upon and
also hard to find any information no
internet you know we barely had a
magazine here and there with it maybe
the electronic gaming monthlies and the
game pros and all that stuff when they
eventually came out you know there was
like there was no resource so if if you
went and found something you truly were
passionate if you traveled to an E3 to
go to a show to you truly were
passionate about it and again it's just
that that love and that passion for the
culture that didn't exist and a lot of
people thought hey is The Fad gonna die
it's not gonna you know what I'm saying
and now look where gaming is right where
it's like biggest in entertainment like
making as much money and rivaling you
know movies and things of that nature
and it's just beautiful to see I just
wanted to Pivot real quick
um final questions is um
you've had so many positive experiences
you know with gaming pop culture your
interviews I've seen a couple of them
you know to be an interview Buff Bagwell
from WCW y'all like like this man this
interview a lot you know rock stars they
so like so many but you have so much
experience so like what are maybe one or
two of your magic moments you know
interviewing or even recently in content
creation whatever whatever way you want
to go with this well I'll go I'll go
I'll take both of those actually okay
let's go the my finalist memory and and
and being a radio DJ and then and then
and then my current where I'm at now
with doing the gamers Council uh which I
really love and very passionate about
but the um I got to do an interview
um with uh Molly Cruz's Vince Neil
and this was six seven months after his
daughter
had died and they were doing a golf uh
rally
uh for her honor for a charity for the
charity for her foundation that he made
for her
and
you know it was
supposed to be a five minute interview
you know on here and then ended up
um because Vince uh as we got to talking
and and I don't think I'm that
comfortable to talk to but but I guess
he felt comfortable enough and probably
because of the weight of the situation
interview went for almost 20 minutes uh
of course it was live we didn't cut or
anything to do it and uh and it was it
was very heartfeld there's part of it we
were we were both crying on the air five
you know because talking about the
situation absolutely kind of tearing up
down a little bit because so emotional
and in the moment and it was so uh it
was so great because he really opened up
about you know my you know her life and
what it meant to him and you know you
you as a rock star you get kind of a
stigma but he's still a human being and
he's a father you know and and you know
all those kind of things we most of us I
assume would know about or or at least
you know to the point where it's you
know family and that's uh it was
important damn and and we talked about
it we got it all out we talked about um
you know the whole the whole project
stuff and then after it was you know
wrapped up send it on to a commercial
and then he's still on the line when we
talked for about another five minutes
and he thanked me probably 10 times
about how much he enjoyed this the talk
and it was just it was good for him and
everything I was to me it was like that
was the best moment and radio
awesome
that's a moment for sure that was cool
sorry oh no no but yeah it was it was it
was pretty cool so awesome and then the
uh and then now where we're going with
the with uh with my podcast which
obviously I'm still doing interviews I
love doing that
but I I actually I was trying to find
somebody that I could have like as a
co-host and and I was lucky uh that I'd
seen Retreat on Boom show and I reached
out to him and talked to him and we kind
of went back and forth and I told him
what my plans were what I wanted to do
and he was like oh my God I had the
exact same idea for a podcast
so I was like oh wow okay so maybe you
want to do your own thing and he's like
you know what I don't know when I'll get
to that point but if you're at that
point and you're ready to do it let's
give it a go and luckily he agreed to do
it and so we have Gamers cancel which is
later on tonight every uh every you know
trying to push that but yeah every
Sunday night longer 7 7 P.M
I love I love doing that and uh and with
him we've had a lot of great guests on
uh we we and you guys know are working
hard so it's incredibly
hard to have you guys as guests because
you guys are sometimes doing five six
hour podcasts and we you know I
understand it so so we've just now
started doing the uh
um um where we have the the members uh
um special edition like uh just for
members only and then like three days
later we drop it for everybody to see
and we were very blessed that King on a
Saturday was available and he came in
and and knocked it out of the park so
our first one was with King and to me it
was like oh God I gotta have the iron
Lords on I gotta get them all on but
this kind of opened up an Avenue before
we could still have you guys maybe sneak
in you know I'm not not pre-asking you
guys for the future maybe you don't want
to be on board needle but anyway but
just to say that you know
so we had we had this it's it's great
we're going awesome I'd love to hear
that thank you sir
um but yeah it's it's uh it's it's been
really fun uh we have a really good show
tonight we got uh we got Harvey Johnny
coming on we got fuzzy Belvedere fuzzy
he's so underrated he's fuzzy is uh his
channel is really good he really gets
into racing yeah and we all need to
subscribe to fuzzy because he he needs
to get the 500 he really does uh and I'm
just saying it and and another person in
the community that's a big pillar that's
on after you guys but before us and our
show is kind of overlap but I'm okay
with that because it's it's fun it's fun
games
is amazing he's oh he's a old guy like
me maybe not as old as me but he's but
he gets you know he's a classic classic
gamer classic guy and and wow I love
listening to him on RDX and uh so yeah
so like when this is over people need to
jump to that oh yeah absolutely nothing
after that then they come to visit us
facts I loved it brother in this gaming
history love the stories man we could
talk to you for hours and just just your
journey brother it's very inspiring and
um I'm glad we I'm glad you know our
schedules was kind of hard to get this
together but you were patient I'm there
for you man and I love it man now when
you know the rules you know any guest in
the realm has to ask the two final
questions in reference to games I I
don't know where he's gonna go with it
on his console but but
um we need from Lord Webb Dave his top
five video game or franchises of all
time
oh yeah let's go Okay so
you know um
big fan of a big fan of Mario okay oh my
real franchise I I like all the Mario
games okay and then a kind of a kind of
an old school
um which to Sega Dreamcast is really
where this came out for me but it was uh
the uh PSO
um
still
me and my son play on a independent a
private server now doesn't cost anything
to play we still play on PC to this day
we did like two weeks ago was last time
we played a lot of fun just you know
three people you know Co-op get in there
and knock it out so yeah so that's a I
love that um
Final Fantasy XI I was really big on
that uh uh I loved
uh and especially I was so happy when it
came kind of relative uh to uh to the to
the Xbox when it you know when it came
to the Xbox it was so so awesome to have
you had to get other disc and everything
love I played that for years let's just
let's just say that then it took up a
lot of time
so and then you know of course the news
the 14 is finally coming down pretty
good too
yeah
that's three gosh
um
two more games are franchise so many
great games man I know but maybe just
you know about like what maybe had more
most impact on you you know maybe not
the not even one of people considered
but maybe it's just something that for
whatever reason was a huge part of your
journey
well I
uh a newer part of my journey that I
really enjoy playing and there needs to
be more games like this is
um
um goes to sushima oh it is a
PlayStation 5 game
oh my God I love that game and if and if
I'm uh you know it's you know I'll I'll
admit I play stealth
app you're preaching
yeah yeah I I I I love that uh if I had
to I had to pick one more
um
man it's uh I said so hard because
there's so many you know great games I I
know the I know the future is coming and
uh you know I really enjoyed you know
playing uh you know like Skyrim and
games like that
um doing it you're doing it
foreign
I'd say probably you know this this
Skyrim slash
anything Bethesda makes
is uh it would be that would be the last
one I guess if that's fair to do
absolutely absolutely yeah that's that
question RPG you know but that's go talk
they would go to that of that um that
whole genre and created the whole space
and Oblivion and Skyrim and then that's
what a lot of people are hoping for
Starfield right that's to continue that
Legacy that we know them I can hardly
wait so you you ain't the only one
brother and the last question that dick
you said this earlier but I need I need
confirmation yeah favorite console of
all time and why
uh Dreamcast because those
Soul Calibur was to me revolutionary so
and it's and that still holds up to this
day it's you could jump in and play it I
mean I mean
and I'd be quite on par with the
graphics of today yes but you could just
you can just see the love and the
development and the quality of that game
was at the time when it came out there
was nothing
preach there you go yeah killer app
killer apps Soul Calibur the tale of
Sword ancestors
was the only one that had Soul Calibur
and virtual Fighters like that um what
uh console again the legendary web Dave
still rock with us for a little bit old
just let me know because I know you got
a show so how much more how much you got
with us just want to make sure I want to
make sure
I can so it's like um
2 30 here so I got to like a easy four
oh okay because you get at least a topic
and a half
whatever it takes no doubt I appreciate
you want me to hang out thank you so
much of course man listen so um
while you look for Super Chat so what
you want uh no the super chats are here
so that's the great part about it let me
see one so before I jump into the Super
chats give me one moment
um we spoke earlier about Lord akw uh
putting up a GoFundMe for um his mom's
going to uh cancer so I'm going to put
the link in the chat
yeah go ahead and do that put that in
the chat give me a moment
so here it is Link in the chat you help
out in any ways you can guys would be
greatly appreciated
from my brothers one of our gaming
brothers
and now let me roll back a little bit
this is I love fan the fan funding isn't
it great this is amazing
I I at first I thought I still had to
keep you know continue copy pasting
though no yeah so we have all right
Nintendo the otaku five dollars to be
chat with no [__] doing doing the behind
the scene fluffing
sure sure
he's in one day in Japan then Final
Fantasy 16 did in a month we outside
okay
[Laughter]
Corey did well five dollars of attack
web Dave sounds like somebody pressing
the play button halfway down on the tape
player
sorry he's got that slow that you know
that low low tone like that very small
radio then we got heated heavy 505
remember for 37 months Lord bronze if I
was Hubert I would have told King's mom
yeah it's mine I will show you when I
leave when I leave is it when I leave
with it in my pocket listen from that
from that moment on Hubert had a Target
on his head
it was on site every time I see it
so the lynx was beefy it's very good it
actually was it was
they actually they made it beefier and
then yeah the funny thing about it is
all they did was because it was long at
first and it just scrunched it yep and
it got fatter
very slick and beefy
there we got heartbeat today with that
damn web Dave is the big money man
let's put the crest in the chat for Lord
bronze Isaac Gentry thank you sir
welcome to the realm appreciate it
and we got sin Vendetta ten dollars
Cog I'm in the middle of listening to
the latest defining Duke and all I have
to say is Maddie is insane baked mac and
cheese is god tier mac and cheese in
fact she has a big it's a victim debate
going on how are you about the littlest
stuff yeah we we we he slammed the wrist
and you know I had the support for the
summit my Seven Brothers you know what
I'm saying I almost have to reset my PC
to get the okay yeah just restart just
restart and shot the black LSM it came
through in droves we we got to correct
the young boy you know just yeah he's
just wrong that's all he ain't been
invited to the cookout yet we got to get
him to the cookout that's all hey yo
[Laughter]
there we have Nam Obama I remember for
23 books
like button for Bread Dave and the Lord
oh man the millions then we have Isaac
Gentry two dollars Brad Davis the next
door neighbor we all need it facts
you notice how he said he had a lot of
new friends
that's how I go that's how I go there we
have Robert Kelly Super Chat next day
we'll say he owns Sega stock
do you say the answer sir he's into
banking I think he's bleeding I can't
hear him nope I said no Okay Google he
said no okay no I just owned uh Sammy
they sold the potato division today
[Music]
we have snack with the five dollars
anyone else beat Shining Force three on
Saturn just to learn that scenario two
and three we're never coming to the US
yes yeah yeah that hurt that sucked yeah
you are finally emulating the translated
versions now on the Ally yes live your
best life live your life baby beautiful
we have Corey Tidwell Super Chat SOB
next to a neighbor wanted to play tickle
Wars
and when you said that he was like you
know y'all playing the game he's like
hey man let's rest yeah
yeah I was like whoa
[Music]
I know
yeah I'm good yeah yo let's find out
you play with my joystick
so King as you said Argy today five
dollars next door neighbor grew up to be
let's play with each other right on top
of it right on topic
his whole life he was just looking out
the window on Saul
definitely window creeping for sure
he's one of those winter creepers that
went from window to window oh
there we have uh then we have Joe Repco
AKA Lord flame member for 33 months look
oh yes as Phil gazed upon the
humiliating defeat the FTC suffered and
Jim bending his knee only one thing was
left to advance the line to square we're
gonna talk about it it's coming up
we got gamer by choice remember for 44
months Lord silver as a gamer I remember
getting bite magazine and entering
programs on Timex Sinclair 1000 with two
kilobytes of memory I love hearing
people gaming history that's right those
old games those old computer magazines
had games that you literally had to type
in the entire program into the computer
so you could have it but they give it
away for free though yes
then we have let me see we have four IQ
no more no less
five euro Super Chat Cog leave Sega and
Japanese devs away from Microsoft what
are you wagyu beef now
get mad at me because we saw a Phil out
there with your girl
like his arm Mr Steve he already he's on
Trey songs Mr Steal Your Girl be careful
if you if Phil can send pictures with
your girl just be careful with your
studio
it's getting real beefy
real beefy like
um
so I'm gonna put in the chat uh a poll
you know they're clearly gonna continue
to put like the beefy emo so I think we
need our own beefy emo yeah it's coming
it's coming a little beefy coming
forward
that's the beat for me that was wild for
that continue we have Spartan to six six
one five dollar Super Chat thank you for
your input on video games sir Lord Webb
Dave it was awesome we gotta jump it was
often awesome to see behind the scenes
everyone should subscribe to your
channel have fun yeah
thank you put in that web Dave chattel
goes to support send some love to our
bro
then we have country big 94 five pound
Super Chat happy Sunday Lords respect to
Webb Dave a great guest just made a new
subscriber out of me let me hold on I
Gotta Give country biggest flowers
because sometimes you don't realize like
wrestler yeah you don't realize who
follows you sometimes and sometimes I'm
a follower for a follow-up person
especially 10 tweet rule you ain't doing
nothing crazy it ain't disrespectful I
don't know how you handle that
I I get I see someone too many times I'm
not interested like I'm tempted to
unfollow like I like this you're you're
your Twitter wall must be the most
diversity yeah
my DMs are crazy everything's great but
I want to shout out too big because when
I looked at his profile I realized I was
like wait a minute this was a real
professional wrestler so salute the
country big British Professor let's go
check him out he's out there in the
circuit you know what I'm saying doing
his things yes that's a hard life that's
real yeah
then we have Corey Tidwell five dollar
Super Chat kids move abandon this post
right before Microsoft deployed the
Autobots to the front line
I I try I was gonna bring kids smooth in
here so he can defend himself but Cog
don't want that
let's not do this today
we're all good all right so what we're
going to do is we are going to
transition to the poll um last week's
poll results are in the people have
spoken with the rumors of a PlayStation
5 Pro scheduled in 2024 can Xbox afford
to stand Pat without a mid-generation
refresh so the choice is the winner of a
three-way ILP poll at 57 percent of the
vote was yes Xbox now has ABK the
studios and exclusive games to funnel
Game Pass consistently this gen group
coming in at second place at 34 of the
vote was no Xbox can't be outdone in the
power narrative and will tool up like
they did with project Scorpio and in
last place at eight percent of the vote
was I don't care none of this matters
until the real champ the Nintendo switch
2 comes into the group salute everyone
that voted I saw I think King's got his
camera off because I was dying to get
his opinion on his the realm disagrees
with cake they actually said yeah
they're eating good so I was curious
what he thought but let's get uh let's
get let's get at it like what what's
your thoughts that the realm is like
yeah we good on on the new system
normally the realm is I mean the whole
Xbox Scorpio I'm winning a new
mid-generation reflect gotta compete
digital Foundry they like nah we good
what do you think
um
I agree and I disagree with King at the
same time I agree with the realm in
terms of if PlayStation doesn't do one
we don't need one but at the same time
like Xbox needs to respond power to
power and I I do feel like if you don't
respond and you go two or three years
because I'll be around the end of the
generation like that last little run but
that two three is gonna be real rough
like
it's it's going to be struggling man you
know and uh if they do like Phil said
truly can consider the Xbox series s to
be their entry uh compared to like the
PS5 being the entry for PlayStation and
the series X is the the next gen upgrade
and they just gave it to them sooner I
think that's a mistake and I think that
would end up blowing in a blown up in
their face in the long run and I just I
just personally I don't see
Xbox just unless the games come out and
they hit it because they don't like look
switch switch can't run anything half
the time but it's got good games so it
sounds it out sells everything
so it's just like it just depends on
what happens you know I don't think that
they're gonna let them run wild with the
weakest console that's just my opinion
yeah I do think that you know they
they'll respond maybe later than we
would like but I do think they will have
one no doubt King the realm rare
disagreement with King they all like we
are good ABK Studios we don't gotta
worry about what PlayStation 5 Pro doing
how to get your thoughts
um nobody needs a PlayStation 5.
like it's not necessary
um and be honest with you I don't even
know what they need the pregnant system
for and all that other stuff they're
doing like you know like the removable
uterus thing oh pause yeah yeah
[Music]
um but I don't know what they need these
things for like I didn't know why they
needed the VR
um you noticed that it hit and then
nobody say nothing it's like it did it
underperformed it didn't sell how it's
supposed to sell somebody's over there
doing a lot of passion projects and
it's kind of scary to me
because I've witnessed the downfall of
Sega and it was like Sega was acting
this erratic way at the end of their
their life cycle as well so
um I don't think that you need a
PlayStation 5 Pro for what for what
utilization will it be like for what
who's calling for this nobody not a soul
is calling for this oh I need more power
than a series X the series X ain't even
using the power that's in a box either
so I would not want Microsoft to do no
um mid-gen
yeah you were sounding last week no but
it's just the fact that they're not
using what they have use what you have
first I can see if you know no Phil is
not going to let the power narrative go
okay this is what I was saying so you
come out with a pro what do you think
you're gonna Flex for a week no Phil's
just gonna put the boot on your neck you
see what he do so you already know that
you're dealing with a petty dude that
don't want you to have anything more
than him so he's trying to actively take
away your narrative so why don't you
just focus on games like why don't you
do that why don't you show us the power
of this so-called Speedy SSD why don't
you do something that that uh shows that
this system has power it's like they
gave up on this system already and this
system didn't even tap into what is
tapping into you know so I I it's for no
reason is pro like it's for no reason
anybody that's championed paying 700 for
something that they're never going to
utilize anyway it's mentally deficient
in an area of you just want to be bigger
and better and that speaks to something
else I don't want it I'm not looking for
it I only brought a PlayStation 4 Pro
because it fixed the problems that I had
with my Playstation One VR that's it
okay not fair enough look I respect the
the the the pivots
no Phil is going to drop a series X pro
because he's not going to lose power
right but if these dudes don't even drop
a pro still won't do it either no I
guess there's no need to do it no I get
it I get it it's a reactionary business
sometimes sometimes at the end of the
day things are already being cooked up
cooked up already from the you know
Chase around on his team and those guys
and look I'm I'm coming around I I in
defensive you I was 60 40 last week
leaning your way right at first you know
maybe they gotta respond they can have
it but then like a lot of people say
like which gen like how many generations
has power really won the more we talk
about web day right you know he's been
through all how did Leo Geo win did the
mass system there's a lot even our
beloved Dreamcast did not win so it's
just like you know it is true to it that
you know it is about the game so I I am
leaning that way and I've come around
I'm like but don't get me wrong if they
decide to make one if you act up you get
smacked up yeah
we're gonna get all of her we're gonna
get all the versions meanwhile
well I don't think Webb was gonna just
Flex for no reason no more
the web looks he looks so comfortable in
his skin like I did yeah he just changed
his day the bread day that's right
Dave let's go he got to break so look
good one all right two patreon um
questions one is a question the other
one's kind of like a statement so let's
shout out to the homies dip down gangs
and Anime salute hey Lords oh here he go
he goes right that's the fight now I see
what he's doing I may not be there live
to see your answers as Lord Amber and I
are officially a lady lady Amber and I
pardon officially getting married salute
that's right huge love salute to dip
down games Anatomy go check them out
anyways in alien race is taking over
Earth due to reasons the four of you
have to select and agree on four video
game characters to defend the world who
are you picking let's start with Atticus
he's so fussy and I want to get his okay
so he picks one I pick one I guess we
could all pick one but we gotta agree on
the four characters video game
characters to save the world from the
Alien Invasion
I know where I'm going but I didn't go
at it because you know if we don't agree
you know how he do he wants everybody to
die he squats her so where we at it what
what are your characters are you picking
to save the Earth video game from Alien
Invasion
I'm picking Goku from the Dragon Ball
games okay okay me and you definitely
online all right I'll let you guys
that time right there is dead who are
you picking to save the world video game
character
I say I mean that there's obvious ones
but I think I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
with Samus oh yo Samus okay all right so
okay and I were talking about the lower
end of that because
there you go well I'm gonna take the
easy one that you're gonna take like I
don't want that do that oh we're trying
to survive not kind of King are you
staying with
God because all of us we're cool with
Goku okay
um Master Chief all right being King is
okay I'm cool master chief I want
matches easy ones all right
you're not going oh God here we go
here we go here we go
stronger than Master Chief it's not
about being stronger sometimes bro
Master Chief's greatest thing is he's
lucky
yeah remember that because his luck
meter is crazy that's why he was
selected so I'm going with the lucky
dude who could come back from adrianos
yes to me we have access to Demons
to mutants
oh like he hasn't done this okay who are
you picking Mr disagreeable okay
yeah he can have Master Chiefs
Goku Master Chief we got two we need to
pick two more people all right all right
sephiroth
okay
he actually has stuff he can contribute
the reason I would give that I kind of
calmed down the master chief ones
because I do think Goku's an idiot so
he's gonna need someone strategist so so
Master Chief probably could be the
strategist and he's a natural leader so
he can probably we got a strategy and
the power right with Goku right I'm
sorry continue
yeah so that that's all all right so we
got those two and then so so does what
about creators obviously let's just
answer the final question is a regular
dude that watching babies now we good
yeah
will join the aliens no
do you what Seth Roth are you
comfortable with him King
um I'm comfortable with Seth roll my
only uh thought process to that is
didn't he get smoked by um clouds
we got smoked by Cloud but he got jumped
by CLA uh by cloud in his friends
y'all gonna laugh at this one that's
true it's true
there is a a finisher that I saw on
Twitter yesterday where Glu King takes
someone into space and and creates a
black hole and drops it up so Kirby
Master Chief Goku and Sephiroth's card
is are we oh are we saying because he
I'm a little nervous with sephiroth yeah
me too I'm telling you
remember what was that 360 game with the
dude that was like
gods
yeah yeah
you know who I should have picked cool
King who I should have picked Marta with
that infinite tsukuyomi oh yeah
because the Naruto games are on Deck
yeah
you know what yeah I Gotta Laugh at this
one too but we've been making a little
bit of fun of this game but it's recent
what
Clive Roosevelt clap clap
[Music]
could barely live in his own world
one more we just got it we got to come
on we just gotta agree on a lot though
hating on Samus man I mean
stronger than Chief not really though
[Laughter]
form or is it Seekers Master Chief from
the rip is who he is right
some of these dudes got to go out and
collect items in order to make it happen
it should have been more specific like
it had to be like a human-like creature
he's an alien an alien race is taking
over Earth due to reasons we have the
fourth we have to select the degree on
four video game characters defend the
the earth
I don't know
you guys tell me what you guys think
should be
what about um
Starkiller
yeah the Earth is safe all right
all right um I really don't see too many
people messing with that group that's a
solid dope it's a solid group it's a
solid group all right this one is not
more of a question but more of a
bars for the room Benjamin amaroo I hope
I pronounced that correct the greatest
day of the week is Once Upon Us while
some may rest their voice the Lords
never go horse man it's not even a
choice United Clans and fans from Far
wide propose for upholding a line above
and beyond any one man's own Pride at
Mission fueled through attrition as each
son
bum burned and bronzed into third then
King shouted shot fired and reignited
the herd Sony's been exposed as the
rabbit in the race shell-shocked as we
Turtle each huddle towards this new
space I guess this is a poem the grass
now is greeter the field is ours time to
raise the competition at Kings plays
Behind Bars that's a wrap sit back as we
set sights for the Stars wanted to
create an energetic flow as we get all
four of the Lords two men two men took a
hurting but they once again raised their
swords I guess that's from last week
though the pen is mightier it's true and
also our pal joysticks could greet back
his only Sovereign with balls no longer
bloom pockets are out in force and the
world will make do salute fam of the
Lord it felt like a general King moment
he says inspired by truth hashtag patent
pending and beefed up through Victorious
acquisition even Cog see as the seized
grinding for corporate position this is
a thing that listens to our party this
man
yeah you know you made it when people
make a poetry about you man it rhymes
about you yo shout out to Benjamin
patriarch questions it's amazing lit
yeah salute salute that was awesome we
appreciate all the fun shout out to dip
down he actually have some really good
face job he makes us fight a lot he does
yeah yeah yeah salute salute all right
finally congrats oh congrats they're
down and Lady dip down during the holy
Bachelor The Royal Wedding go support
dip down gaming we gotta play uh I like
put that stuff in the chat man we gotta
give dip down some love everyone's got
some good patreon writers because that
was one we actually we came together on
that one we didn't die like last week
all right so we got to get to these
topics this is me let me get this we got
a couple yeah
she's Augustus remember for 23 months
Lord bronze I would rather have a series
s portable than a series X pro gaming
handheld to the move for the future go
buy a rock let's go yeah get that wrong
let's go then we got Pat f i put the
crust in the chat for Pat F welcome to
Lord bronze to the realm appreciate you
Spartan 6615 Super Chat every Sunday is
an event with three shows and every
Sunday is like a Super Bowl weekend
picking a team is useless all teams are
awesome love all shout out appreciate
that yo they killing that he said addict
votes for all villains and Aliens
yojitsu Sage is on you Goku's not a
villain he said he's working for the
aliens only way you beatbox not a
villain I I agreed to uh to Master Chief
he's not a villain I agree Seth Roth is
a villain he's kind of anti-villain I
feel like Shinra was the big the villain
of the actual Wave by Sage you covered
for the roar addict did not name it was
Saul who named sephiroth he said a
Trader who sided with Genova an alien
and that's fine but you know don't
mispronounce don't misspell my name
I like I like that team but y'all messed
up with Azura yeah I really did
I mean me and you played that game yeah
you know all we had to do
is put care from Death Note in there you
just kill everyone
anime characters video game guys please
please
I don't think deathton has a game so
that wouldn't work they talk with the
addict yeah we have no Metroid Samus
Iran wise decision soft thank you
appreciate that absolutely sorry I got
voted off the island
already did well 2000 but Jack King said
some of these dudes do some XP
salute
five pound super chat if police station
thinks they need a midgen if they need a
midgen they can go crazy Xbox has mine
share and the studios casuals don't care
for 20 teraflops 12K super rain
that's true what the hardcore dude
and hardcore is not buying it does the
hardcore has 40 40 90 so that's it yeah
then we got dump remember for 18 months
Lord bronze if you could keep one
classic Xbox IP and all the studios were
focused on new IP what classic IP do you
think Xbox should continue forward with
what yeah what if if you could keep one
classic Xbox IP and all the studios were
focused on New Life on that new IP I
guess what classic IP do you think Xbox
should continue forward with if
everybody were working on one game
Halo it needs to be back to Greatness
yeah I'm going to put all the resources
in Taylor don't play around with that
oh you just want them to help them out
with it no they just say Xbox time I
mean I is it not Bethesda because Xbox
owns with us no I'm just curious I guess
he said OG ogip so yeah well then it
would be either be Halo or fable or the
other two fair enough fair enough let's
go we are caught up finally first topic
y'all here we go oh goodness back to
normal back to normal down all right all
right
wow this is crazy um yeah B Final
Fantasy 14 online coming to Xbox series
consoles in Spring 2024 and uh during
the Final Fantasy Fan Fest 2023 the game
director nayoki Yoshida Yoshi Pete
Welcome to our Xbox head Phil Spencer
onto the stage alongside Square Enix CEO
Takashi Kiryu to celebrate the Xbox
release announcement for Final Fantasy
14. on stage curio make the following
statement and one more thing as CEO of
Square Enix we want to continue to
deliver fabulous games to fans across
the world and of course we want to
welcome the Xbox Community as well and
starting with today's announcement of
Final Fantasy 14 coming in Spring 2024
and whenever is possible we are planning
to bring our games to Xbox for players
around the world to enjoy we really look
forward to working closely with Phil and
the Xbox team to make this possible in
response Phil Dominus Maximus are really
expensive Gotta Give Kids thank you you
curiosak and we deeply respect the rich
Legacy of Square Enix and we look
forward to building on the relationship
that we've established in bringing Final
Fantasy for kiggins out of pocket sound
like a new boyfriend
I really respect you love
sorry you're going on stage with it and
Alfredo Fantasy 14 to the Xbox and
partnering closely with you and the
Square Enix team on future games and
then following that also this week we
saw from the official Final Fantasy um
Twitter account says announcing that uh
Final Fantasy 14 Xbox series X and S
following an open beta test during patch
6.5 we'll proceed to the official
release but in Spring 2024 on Xbox so
this kind of broke late luckily the
Lord's got this new cycle it's been
breaking the internet but I gotta I'm
gonna break protocol a little bit with
Dave because I do have to ask
one particular Lord
you know he he loves these square games
you know we we in a situation that we
probably never have no clue who you're
talking about we never thought this
might happen and then you know the
following week it just so happened and
this particular Lord and King we're
having a discussion about Squidward so I
gotta know breaking how's my brother
feeling Lord addict Square Enix Final
Fantasy 14 more square games on the on
the way and the public display of Phil
Spencer Square Enix CEOs where are you
at with this well the tears of
PlayStation fans was pretty nice I will
say that uh the second thing I'll say is
when it comes to just this particular
announcement it's cool I see 14 14 is a
very beloved game a lot of people love
14. I'm just not one of them
so you know I'm glad that we were able
to get that on the platform because I
feel like there's very few things that
will get that much said this might not
get awareness to turn based final
fantasies like the older ones or or like
the newer ones they're giving out but
this will give awareness to the Final
Fantasy brand on Xbox because this this
world is built entirely around final
fantasies like you know our raid bosses
yeah they're
summonses so you know you you literally
there's raids you fight Bahamas oh
that's fine there's there's so many
raids that have summons for losses a
variety of things and I do think this is
a phenomenal game to be in Game Pass I
don't I don't want I want wait they
didn't they didn't say Game Pass no but
it's no no I'm just talking about free
to play to level 70. okay I'm just
talking about Xbox the general knowledge
I said Game Pass okay
so like when it comes to that I really
enjoy that but I do want people to put a
little bit of a break like just pump the
brakes just a little bit ain't doing
that because this this doesn't mean
they're bringing remake I do think this
is
I do think this is really good for the
relationship we'll probably see like the
octopus traveler 2 come to the platform
now we'll see you know there is a
rumored Final Fantasy Tactics okay uh
the the original one I think it's lion
uh Lions war or something like that I
can't remember the the because they made
a Final Fantasy Tactics on the PS1 and
then they remade it on the Vita and I
can't remember I think it's Lions board
someone in the chat there's over a
thousand people in that chat hit that
like button someone in the chat correct
me what war of lines yeah yeah so I
think that remake probably shows up on
Xbox so maybe not day and date because
this relationship is is relatively new
we might not see the bearer of fruit
going into this I don't think it's new I
think they've been dating
yeah I think when it comes down to this
it's very good you know I I think we'll
once these contracts start to to wear
out you'll see Final Fantasy VII come
out and then you know maybe maybe King
right and I had to eat a chip oh he
actually said it no my my man ain't
eating no chip like on God and them I
don't care you can give me your knees
I'll get help so we do something else
but
um no but let me I gotta ask you this
because
this is for years you've been
you've been on the front line with this
you've been the guy I I made a video
yeah I have over
60 videos talking about Square Enix
games on Xbox like like what like what
was it surprising you like that like
what did it feel did you feel like yo
this is um they really improved they're
really gonna try to do something like
how does this feel for you you've been
wanting this for so long I had two
thoughts I'm like oh snap 14's coming on
Xbox that's crazy and then my after
thought was
but it's not seven rings
well it's a good really really good four
step forward it's like I said okay in a
lot of ways having this game come on
Xbox is bigger than having remake come
on Xbox because people don't realize
how popular this game is
insanely popular uh you know they they
you could pick classes from from all the
final fantasies just about you know in
Final Fantasy 10 Aaron has like this
right uh this red I think it I don't I
don't know exactly what the name of it
would be like they they they go to that
detail like you can get the stuff that a
lot of the Final Fantasy characters wear
like it it's an understatement to say
this isn't one of the most popular MMOs
that's in existence right now wow and
it's never been on Xbox like you know
and I think that this game coming is
just it coming to Xbox is going to give
way more
presence and awareness on Xbox because
it's free to play up to level 70. and
you're able to just jump in there it's
going to get more Awareness on the Xbox
brand of Final Fantasy then Final
Fantasy 7 remake what okay yep because
remake is just one game
you play Final Fantasy 14 you're you're
meeting characters from the other games
yo what what's what's this dude in here
for what game he go to you know what I'm
saying like I think it'll give more
regulation in the long run but until we
started this is uh chess not checkers
it's it's this is like
setting this is like
starting out with the pawns first like
like the the and and I do think that
this is going to
set a domino effect where hopefully
you'll see maybe not the final fantasies
that score Enix is is has secured but
like I said the octopi traveler twos and
Final Fantasy 9 remake keep in mind
there's more remakes it's not just
ending at seven so they're trying to
stop them gains from missing Xbox and
then you like I said Final Fantasy
Tactics uh War of the Lions remake
that's that's rumor to be coming and not
to mention Dragon quests they're trying
not to stop them from not coming to the
franchise before yo and it's like I said
if they bought Square Enix
I don't think it's happening but if they
bought Square Enix
I played Tetris for a whole two hours
look this is this is a big deal I'm glad
that you got your respect let's go back
to normal format with our guest Lord
Webb Dave you know don't know how your
connection is with square you know
square games in general but just you
know how do you feel about this news
what the significance of this news with
uh Phil Spencer and obviously Square
Enix this uh Fan Fest in this kind of
public statement you know forward-facing
statement towards the community
it is big really big
um I mean
this is something that we've been
wanting on and Phil commented on
that they wanted to have happen 10 years
ago when it first came out
so it is uh it is
hard to
there was one uh video that's going
around on Twitter of of a person who was
watching the show and when he they
announced Phil Spencer
and you could see it on his face Phil
Spencer and then he just starts going so
crazy and excited and then crying at one
point and people like he's excited over
Phil Spencer he's like no he's he's a
super passionate gamer about Final
Fantasy 14 and his the realization that
the game that he loves is finally coming
to the platform he loves
this is cosplay too yes exactly cross
play so now you can play because
my son and my daughter both play the
hell out of 14. really and uh and
already in fact well we have we have
messages already going there like you
know so they're gonna
help me level
they're gonna carry you through the
destiny raid I love this I love this
they're gonna carry the old man I love
this
exactly exactly because it's it's you
know like I said I was 11 for a long
time really big fan of playing 11 and uh
you know 14 is is good and and I know
like uh miles Don Pierre was saying that
you know maybe this means that they can
bring games uh like the Mana series you
know and there's a lot of those and and
maybe you know they've already announced
that it's coming you know Kingdom Hearts
four well maybe now Kingdom Hearts four
can make its you know can make its way
to uh to Xbox which would be great
because the other ones have been on Game
Pass at one time so real quick go ahead
Dave I'm looking up like The Raid like
big bosses that's in you got the
Ultimate Weapon uh Behemoth the thing
that was in 15. Odin you got Ifrit Titan
guard uh Gardia like I definitely
butchered that you guys can make fun of
me it's funny yeah okay uh no Sheva you
got um Phoenix another Odin like this
this isn't just a game that this is a
game that's heavily dipped in the Final
Fantasy sauce
the lore continue Dave yeah I agree that
that's huge any other statements oh you
were good
it's really good for the gaming
community
and for Phil to make a special
appearance there it shows to me yes
and that's nothing to end to the world
of gamers
go ahead Kingdom Hearts four
right that that that's a game that is
probably gonna come out the next couple
years and this early work might lead to
that game not skipping the platform it's
a good point that was a good point well
I hear what Dave was saying in reference
to
um you know the symbolism right so if
Phil be in there so I gotta get to Lord
SOB I'm very curious
you know Final Fantasy 14 coming to
series X more square games on the way
what are your thoughts on this one
yeah like I said yesterday on uh on
Khalif show like it's shout out to Phil
and the team for doing the work I think
the sad part about it is that they had
to do the work because if you look at
you look at the relationship in the 360
generation even going into the beginning
of the Xbox one generation we still got
you know
right after ff12 we got 13 right 14's
gifted but I understand why 14 skipping
Xbox initially because it was it's an
MMO you build it for one platform and
then you see where it goes from there
right it's a lot it's a lot of money and
resources and time to build an MMO for
multiple platforms especially when you
talk about the console space and not the
PC space which is just a bigger sort of
platform unto itself so I understood
that but beyond that everything was
coming to the to the to the console you
know Kingdom Hearts 3 came day and date
right to Xbox so it's just it just sucks
that the work had to be done because
somewhere along the lines that
relationship broke down and the
communication wasn't there and and for
whatever reason you know and then you
start besides the the cultural stuff
where it's like oh Xbox players don't
like those type of games which is BS
um you have to you know you have to get
around that whole narrative and
conversation and Phil has to you know
basically go in there and tell them why
it's beneficial to put their games on
the on the platform and he managed to do
it yeah he managed to do it with the
game that is still super popular all
these years later
um but you can't really say no to having
a larger player base when you have an
MMO right like that's why I laughed a
couple weeks ago we had Jazz we was
talking about he didn't want anybody to
touch his precious World of Warcraft oh
my God you bugging
man listen you need as many eyes on this
as possible so I you know I'm not gonna
play it it's not for me I'm not gonna
delve into all that but the fact that
it's gonna be there right is is a huge
huge deal and it does bode well for
everything else coming down the pipeline
even the stuff that we that Xbox has
been sort of uh you know denied up until
now are you are you implying that former
denied games could be should be between
the Xbox it absolutely should be there's
no reason PlayStation have no horse in
this race at this point when it comes to
ff7 like it shouldn't especially not the
original the the original remake right
um we didn't see the contracts though
what if the car yeah it was like a death
Loop situation
I should I would hope not I see it I
understand why right I understand why
right but with Phil saying more games
are coming yes my hope is that that was
one of the first things on the table
right that in 16.
um right and unless there is some you
know ground and stone uh contracts that
cannot be undone or anything like that
nature and at the very least he is
talking about the stuff the addict was
talking about the stuff down the
pipeline to make sure that is coming to
the console uh day and day right and
then you have the game pass equation and
I will say this right let's say let's
say Phil going over there all these
years I mean trying to you know reforge
this relationship let's say that's still
been a tough sell just for the business
aspect of it right
Xbox is in spend mode bro they're in
spend mode and they are not obviously
they're not above having to be like
listen man if you're telling me we need
to help you build the version for Xbox
because it's monetarily you feel it's
not in your best interest the return is
not going to be what you want it to be
we will do that right and I see Phil
laying down on that sword and be like
hey man do you do we need to see these
games on this platform it is what it is
so I can see that being a scenario as
well where they're helping to build
these Xbox versions of these games
monetarily real quick well I want to
push back on that is
I I'm okay with them making that those
initial
pushes but what I'm scared of is like in
the long run
those companies feel comfortable with
Microsoft paying for the ports every
time oh 100 because then it's like I
think that's just putting a Band-Aid on
on a bro on a cut because it's not going
to fix the issue because what's going to
happen is now I've gotten used to like
one or maybe two iterations of a game a
couple installments and then when
Microsoft's like when we're not paying
for the for for it anymore we're not
going to continue to pay for your ports
that's actually kind of your job then
okay we're not doing it no more well
this no I don't think that's gonna
happen you know why because I I think
that's a conversation Phil gold Phil's
going into this conversation knowing
that full well and if he's willing to do
that this is this is going to be hey
when we see this level when we see this
level of engagement right
well at that point
the proof is in the pudding and you're
going to have that level of engagement
on this platform moving forward you
should be able to Port these games
yourself and we'll we'll talk about
money at that point but I don't think
there's any need for us to now have to
support that development because it's
we're showing you that the platform is
viable for your game right all that old
stuff that you were throwing out at us
cool got you not anymore and I and I see
I can see that argument happening at it
but I see Phil already being prepared
for that I feel you I feel you it could
be just like you know conditions that
like you know we have no problem or
maybe they're one of those things like
you know we'll keep fronting the bill
until you start seeing an audience on
our platform then yeah 100 when we hit
that then you'll start fighting a bit
that's 100 if that is the scenario right
or a scenario
I see that the battle of the monster
Hearts oh
[Music]
this is the thing about you came though
right look at you you don't know how to
win yeah you can't win nicely no we
can't win
you get a W's
here it's my win I do with it
Let me refresh my memory did they close
the deals the next day like you said
they were going to
um I I thought the deal was gonna close
the Monday after okay okay
sometimes
this is for you
yeah
yeah sir yo so now so now Phil going in
with a contingency plan is mustard heart
no no because he went in there and he
went in there through the meat on this
who he himself has said I've been over
there for years trying to reforge this
all of a sudden he went over there with
meat on the table again that's that's
how it went down it didn't go down that
way you know you know what's funny and
you know how to go down muster Hearts
like to revise whatever they want to do
you want to listen to y'all guys talk
and y'all was doing the battle of the
mustard Hawk
continue to continue too much that's all
I would say all I'm saying it may
behoove you someday to take ow with a
bit of humility
I'm not doing that I'm gonna take my w
how I like it I like I like my w with a
little sauce
you don't like my W's
that was a slathery monster
this is beautiful but only thing you do
remember is these wins oh my God so let
King go so that he could oh basically
reiterate what I say and try to say
basically obliterate try and basically
and try to say it in a different way
that makes the sound like Phil walked in
there with his chest out because he
didn't do that yo I'm gonna show you
where you're wrong I'm gonna tell you
right now
let you finish
the man went over there with humility as
he should have
and he got the job done and I appreciate
that he ain't going there swinging no he
was he wasn't throwing hammocks
listen I know I know what I saw oh here
we go you know where we go my man ain't
had no my man ain't had no mustard
this is King making inferences from
pictures this is the Miss Cleo king
version video my man came out looking
like Goldberg
he came out yo this is where I broke his
head you came out you can't front when
they had just [__] electricity and
the lights
two dollars
do not associate me please
you you know obviously the the
discussion last week was very prophetic
because um we we did talk about Square
Enix and you had some very strong
proclamations you you had a bend the
knee I will say I went from zero percent
chance of that happening to like a 15
now we gotta give King his flowers we we
all looked at him again like we always
do when he makes both Proclamation
sometimes like yo that's wild he really
saying this like acquisition of square
eatings without any information and then
boom and that shows up on stage like
King I gotta like what is going through
your mind right now when you see Phil
Spencer on stage with Square Enix heads
talking about this relationship and
let's be clear this relationship has
been Rocky and inconsistent at best for
the last couple of years so what do you
make of this and do you still stand on
your theory then
let's go check it out the only thing
that's been Rocky and inconsistent was
the old CEO
money was on the table this is before
the AKA
um ABK deal money was on the table yo
listen we want to do this we want to do
that we want to purchase this and it was
a deal in place
Microsoft came back to the table
so yo like nah we need more bread on
that like you know you saw somebody
wallet before they left and they came
back you raised the price oh man so
that's where the the talks was breaking
down then ABK uh became available and
they was like let's let's go handle that
real quick we can double back on these
dudes because there was a point in time
where
tons of uh Square Enix games was showing
up on Game Pass that is true
and nobody thought that you would get uh
any of the Kingdom Hearts seriously on
Game Pass like all of them showed up and
then all these obscure Final Fantasy
games started showing up and we was like
yo what's going on with this
relationship where they going with it
well come to find out when the ABK
information came out the stuff that Sony
did not want you to see
um somebody had a whole dossier
it's true they pulled out this is the
square folder
and in that folder they had everything
all the ins and outs and they were
approved for purchase like they were
this is the higher-up said yeah we see
what y'all doing we like that we
purchased them
okay so that information is there so
we're trying to figure it out like oh
snap all right so the double back
happened so what happened what do you
think happened wrong so as soon as this
time these dudes is over there they feel
like all right back on the grind grind
never stops when you're a hustler Ryan
never stops so he was like all right
back to what I was talking about back to
my regularly scheduled program went
right over back to Japan new CEO in
place new CEO in place uh forget the
gentleman's uh cure you and um yeah the
former he took over from uh what's his
name yasoki Masada so he stepped down as
president and then Takashi Kiryu is now
the new product and I believe the timing
was very interesting in conjunction to
this announcement because I believe it's
um he the new CEO started in June and
Final Fantasy 14 Xbox announced in July
I I used to watch called bunk and there
was an episode where the mayor what
what's the thing would you do when you
get someone out of jail you um pardon
them yeah so there's a criminal that the
mayor wouldn't pardon so that Chrome's
like we gotta get that mayor up out of
here because we have chosen to success
dude that's boy
boy
it's like we can't buy the company so
we're gonna buy the leaders they put a
new guy in a little bit more agreeable
no I don't I don't even think what
you're saying is is factual what you
think I'm just joking
I don't think they literally went in
there and said we're gonna no that's
gonna give you a paycheck to get no
that's done that's the hard version of
it but let me give you the real version
of it
we want to be sold the boy like we want
to be sold we don't pretty up ourselves
we don't we don't separate it from Iowa
we don't did all this other stuff
Dynamics with everybody gone and we
don't have the person in place that got
to keep vetoing what we want to do so
you know what we're gonna give you all
if you can't refuse you got to get up
out of here and um you take this
severance package you disappear the
moment that he takes a several package
and disappear the most uh accoladed MMO
is showing up Final Fantasy 14. yeah
okay they had a private investigator to
walk in if you like are these you in
these pictures
they had the dossier and he slid it out
and said
in this shot with this was this you
hitting her
oh
he said he said
the investigator leaves then Phil walks
in and fills this down so what's up yeah
they did your silky like that my suit
inside like that yeah so so shout out to
y'all and the new CEO
greeting Phil if y'all look at the the
the
um the picture when they all hold their
hands with the Kumbaya yes yes
they had to show you on the stage
this is real this is happening for days
I said something about lifting something
at an envelope and king oh so happened
listen I'm I'm about that life I'm about
this podcast in life you call it I got
it but
the thing about it is Phil is ready he's
not he's not about going to Japan and
playing around and having drinks and not
making moves he's there to make moves he
came out of the Restless tunnel people
to arouse and Applause so we're gonna
have all right to hell with all the
monster heart talk everything's showing
up B everything everything is showing up
everything Final Fantasy
you're saying a bag wasn't involved in
them no listen money's always involved
in everything that's what I said no no
no no no no no no no no you said it must
have harder way
not like how you not like how you
talking though
everything's coming
watch this right
watch when that ABK deal is complete
who's next everybody keep yelling out
Sega no Sega next in line
there was
there was a dossier bro like if you go
into the into the FBI uh Department
these faces are the one yeah you know
they have a folder with your face on it
you know imagine imagine that it's next
time like you go into that thing and ABK
goes and then it's like yo why is there
an X over our logo oh cause we got you
yo look like the dossier if if you want
to talk about Adrian's office and your
face is on a folder start getting your
Affairs in order
they got information
do you find this weird this is this is
not weird this is not coincidence the
next people they pick up is square the
next day gonna go buy them outright
whatever's gonna happen is gonna happen
so if you have those little contracts in
the background and Final Fantasy can
never make it when we buy you and guess
what's gonna happen
what I love about Phil
Dominus Maximus really expensive first
of his name who did that for you okay
huh who did that for y'all who Who had
who when y'all when y'all boot up that
Final Fantasy
I play Final Fantasy on my PlayStation I
mean the service was trash but this guy
said
I want this because like addict said
this is gonna give me the most
visibility
I don't want a one and done
I want something that's gonna last in
perpetuity that Final Fantasy is
associated with this console so once I
get the millions of MMO players over
here then check that out and have that
Curiosity then we're gonna release the
hounds on them
when they purchase Square
I just want y'all all to come back here
and just give me my flowers I told you a
week before it happened what was gonna
happen then you're so like on a Thursday
like Phil is outside and he's holding
hands on the stage and all PlayStation
dudes uh we don't really like 14 anyway
shut up I'm so tired I'm so tired of you
you you hold everything cherished to
your heart and what Phil is doing is
he's little by little removing all the
cards out of your hands best hand of
Yu-Gi-Oh I've ever seen in my life my
guy he put that death card down you know
that card that you can't move left and
you can't move right and that Dragon
come out and nothing that you do is ever
gonna stop it that's when you're
becoming at and my app predictions for
you guys is happening every day and it's
exhilarated it wasn't for this King
they're coming for this I just had to
put on a Crown because y'all forget who
I am sometimes y'all forget who the hell
I am and y'all out here oh King is
talking out his butt yeah but my butt
and Phil went over there and said
I want you
and I'm gonna have you
you can do that anyway
yeah
we think that like Microsoft's good like
well obviously not King but you know
obviously Acquisitions is
something in their future and we think
yeah babe maybe we ain't put two or
three maybe this oh I had it coming
around
maybe they just going for Sega they
ain't just gold I mean maybe they go for
the whole street but we be this is the
thing right when especially with the
GamePad it's the game pass is the key
right because if without Game Pass you
could say okay we're gonna buy these
these Studios or whatever and we're
gonna sell games the way we know always
have and we're gonna keep doing the way
what we're doing game bad says the whole
equation because Game Pass now you they
need to own everything what does it what
does it behoove them to pay a million
millions of dollars for rentals of games
why right so
game passes to play they're going to
keep buying it's never going to stop
it's never going to stop so solve I mean
be careful because you know people get
so sensitive when you talk consolidation
in the industry
like that people are going to say we're
fun to do today
you're voting for the death of the
industry no it's just this is the thing
all right I'm voting for the deficit you
know what you know what bothers me about
that you act like that like this whole
other aspect of the game industry can't
continue to thrive and and grow the way
it's doing I see that PlayStation is
take taking the baby steps right they've
done this stuff with the PS Plus or
whatever the fact of the matter is
they're still very successful at selling
games the way they sell them yep and
remove from that right
it doesn't to me it doesn't behoove them
to try to continue to to Wade in waters
that Xbox has gone in keep doing what
you're doing keep giving people those
250 million dollar day one you know
bangers or whatever and and keep doing
that to me this the idea that game pass
becomes so big that it gets they swallow
up PlayStation as well I mean that that
actually could happen but what I mean
what I mean is that the two different
ways of thinking continue they can
survive because you see Nintendo at I I
refuse to keep seeing Nintendo this
other thing you see Nintendo continuing
to do things their way and be successful
I don't see the direct comparison being
an issue go ahead the funny thing solve
like I might go on here and cap a lot
for them to buy Sega Sega is a dream
score Enix to me is a fantasy yeah
literally
literally it is literally but the thing
is I would lose my I lose my my stuff if
they bought a second if they bought
Square eggs I might I might have just
passed away from from a heart attack I
don't know if my mind could not concept
that it's crazy it is crazy because
first of all the cultural stuff right
yeah the idea of going into purchasing a
Japanese company that way not like a
third-party way right not not the way
they did it with uh with with Bethesda
right and and um in the studio over
there they if you buying a Japanese
company directly as an American company
stop smiling stuff they're gonna say you
don't know what you're wishing for yeah
they said you it's a sad future be
careful though don't cheer yeah that's
you know what I'm tired of that that
talk it is ridiculous change happens all
the time and change can suck change is
not something that any of us want
especially swapping change the way we're
seeing in the game industry but the fact
of the matter is you know know how they
say you know it was the Jurassic Park
saying life finds a way it finds a way
it's just everybody's going to adapt how
they need to adapt but I firmly believe
that PlayStation can keep doing what
they're doing as long as the quality is
there they don't have missteps with dumb
things like again I I as a PS VR2 owner
it's a great piece of tech that is
collecting dust in my house and there
are some games that are cool but they
don't even promote it like I they don't
even promote it so stuff like that just
keep focusing on the great games figure
out more ways to make them faster right
and and expand that way obviously you
have your service games coming that
hopefully one or two hit and it's gonna
bolster your bottom line there
this idea that game the game pass is
going to become so big that nobody's
going to see beyond that and no other
way of selling games is going to be
viable is is stupid to me it is just
fear-mongering I don't understand it I
really don't understand it listen
there's a lot of stuff going on this was
this was super surprising I'll jump in
yeah I didn't I didn't see this coming I
know you know Phil and the team I've
always said they want to improve that
relation but it really got bad I think I
think you know what especially the
Remake Final Fantasy 7 remake you know
at one point we did see verbiage that
okay after one year it'll come right and
then you know obviously octopath comes
out you know you see part one and then
part two comes out like where's this
where's the pixel remaster I lost my
marbles over octopus travel too oh I
know you did you know listen shout out
to Flame um in in the chat you know he's
he's a big octopath guy as well as far
as well as Maddie and you just start to
see the inconsistent and I do think
there's a lot of Truth to what king is
saying and ref it's to some way that
relationship went really bad with the
previous CEO now I think King has a good
theory you know look we gotta Bender
need a cake let's just call it like we
ain't even playing with you bro like you
you beyond knowing some Snapchat right
now you're on your driver ever since the
whole the line movement you you you will
be on fire but the thing what I got to
give you is like
to see this is very symbolic right it's
very symbolic and we didn't see this one
coming right so look they're looking to
improve the relationship you know for
this what I think I think that at the
end of the day
we have to give Phil his flowers and
this is why a lot of people I know they
oh he lies oh you know I don't
understand why Xbox fans Revere him
right these are the reasons why because
again it's looking at the console
objectively and all their weaknesses and
all their faults right and since his
Inception into the brand it's been a
systematic fixing of things that Xbox
fans have wanted right so it's just like
man systems underpowered all right boom
Here Comes Xbox One X hey Here Comes
this amazing service that is game passed
it starts to become a trend and it's
like the talk was they ain't never going
to do nothing in Japan we never going
like it was always these roadblocks and
then again regardless to you can poo-poo
it and say oh bro just one game though
right but there's symbolism to what king
is saying in reference to going over
there get it here's the thing that I
thought was interesting no one's really
talk about the Square Enix account
tweeted this and put the Emojis about
you know Xbox and you know we're excited
you know to see what's going on like
this is a full
unified front marketing right yep not
just one side say hey guys we we did it
we got the the the team that has been
resisted is saying hey guys we did this
too so again I don't know what it means
for the future you know what it means I
know you know you got you know by
looking when are we gonna stop
questioning because it's just baffling
to us right like this is happening
because this is changing right oh what
it is is let's let's keep it above
they were putting theyself up we thought
they were putting themselves off of Sony
right
then we started seeing all these games
and landing on Xbox right
and then the APK thing went and then
something weird happened yes right I
agree with your theories yeah that sound
is like some jilted situation say like
we know they were on the marriage list
right right to be put a ring on their
finger and they got theoretically let's
say they got theoretically left at the
order
ABK happens you're stopping everything
you do I got to go get Beyonce because
yeah like ABK wasn't on the list right
right so we know that is something that
literally happened fell from this guy
like oh they they down and we could get
that they were they were probably just
as shocked that they were able to buy
ABK as we were when we found that they
were buying anything exactly so that
happens let's say Square relationship
was talking through this this list right
right as well as other companies Bungie
was on that list you saw everybody that
was on the list either in a holding
pattern or got acquired by someone else
because embracer then grabbed up the
square remember Square started exactly
Crystal Dean all that stuff started
happening so the reason why people like
yo is y'all y'all camping for a 14 year
old game you got to look at the Tea Leaf
they also said future games it didn't
just say oh this is just one game and
that's what's coming out in the future
right so the Final Fantasy and remember
when I said right that I and I can still
play that Final Fantasy remake yet but
something is holding me back and I said
I'm not playing until it come out on
that Xbox you have said that that you
was gonna do it and I want to see it
done I I just know how Petty my dude is
and I know that when I fight when I
stream fight of five was only over there
and he said I wanted to play Street
Fighter on my mind yeah he said and
it'll never happen again we was like you
don't got no control well Street Fighter
6 is on Xbox right now right now yeah I
remember the days when Tekken wouldn't
make the platform he was like that's
again this is why he is revered by Xbox
fan like every issue for the most still
a lot of stuff but you can't take away
the course correction during his regime
you can't take that away from him and
you can't take away game pass so again
there's always going to be ups and downs
but if you look at the resume
objectively it is very impressive what
he's doing to try to turn the brand
around you cannot take that away from
him okay I would say right now
you can make a strong argument he's the
you can make a noun you can make it now
absolutely I think
if he continues it's the only thing that
Phil has lacked in my opinion is a
consistent quality the quality games
if he leaves after he's achieved that
right you can make an argument he's the
best executive ever be in gaming yeah if
he's able to achieve that that you know
if if Starfield comes out and it's a hit
Fable comes out because I consider even
though let's say he retires in two years
even at two years
I would still give him stuff like Fable
because the majority that's like it's
like we said like the the dometric error
the Phil Spencer era like even after he
leaves those first couple games is still
going to be under what his leadership
was and if he can self-correct and
people get like this twisted like he has
had good games in his era yeah yeah like
butts
for every great game like a gears five
yeah it's been something that was
underwhelming like a rap absolutely
absolutely and I think that is the
biggest thing that's holding him from
being like one of the best yeah
Executives ever for me I'm just I know
kids will be mad when I put the cherry
on a Sunday so to speak for me as far as
regimes as far as Xbox leadership right
it's always going to be Peter Moore here
like Phil you can make an augment his
already I'm just gonna wait until the
star feels the the hell blades the Fable
just as long as they're good if they
come out and they're good then that's
his class of 2018. yeah that's his draft
picks that's them bearing fruit if that
his draft picks bear fruit and execute
between him and Peter Moore is
Peter Moore established pillars yes yes
all right and um
that's that's the only thing that he has
to do you know he he established
platforms he made Xbox uh a brand that
you can stand behind right
Game Pass he's done these things
but at the end of the day like yeah they
can like use a solid web Dave
it's about them games and if those games
don't hit then he gonna hit so he got he
got to land those games so starfield's
gonna land and I think Sofia starts to
turn I think starfield's Game of the
Year this year anyway so I think it's
good it's gonna be big I'll just finish
up real quick and just say look this was
I'm with King there is a lot of
symbolism here I don't know if this is
going to mean an acquisition but there's
a lot of symbolism here and and he knows
that by going on stage with Yoshi p and
getting that deal done as well as looks
like you know future partnership is
going to improve it feels like it's
going to improve based on the comments
we're seeing from both sides it's a big
deal and um again I I just Hawken back
to I want to give them their flowers as
far as what they've done in Japan you
know shout out to the Queen Sarah Bond
you know took pictures with her took
pictures
I like to celebrate people in the game
and actually do things and you know that
I meet but um anyway John Jokes Aside
but I do think that they have been on a
mission since the Tokyo game shows the
last two three years to continue to make
the groundwork to put in the work to to
improve that and you like to see it and
that as a person who enjoys playing on
the platform these are the these are
those missing things these deficits that
they're trying to I just want to get
Dave's real quick thought on hierarchy
as far as but then we move on um as far
as Phil's you know um leadership and as
far as his tenure excuse me his tenure
at Xbox like what do you see because I
know there's a lot of criticism
sometimes and rightfully so we saw the
redfall stuff we saw some things that
durian like yo what's going on 2022 how
do you know first party games whatever
whatever but like now that you're
looking at this where we sit now and
then for the future will you have him in
Xbox hierarchy so to speak
it real quick before you go Dave I did
put a question in the chat real quick I
want the Roman to answer just get a
little bit more Vibe on what kind of
guest you guys would like continue yeah
I'm sorry yeah get right there
yeah none like Dave
you're Legend out here oh thank you sir
um no to me uh Phil
um
he's he's he is now the goat
what gave him the gold title to you I'm
curious well I mean if it wasn't for
Phil
um he wouldn't he went to Satya and said
look
you know there's some things we need to
do inside he's like well we're big on
service what can we do about Game Pass
so they they hammered that out and said
look get these benchmarks on Game Pass
let's grow that because that's our
service games and and I'll back you and
support games if you can get this done
he's done that and continues to do that
he also is the man that came out on
stage and said backwards compatibility
oh yeah and we were like what you know
and that was that was big and to this
day I mean I mean you look at things
like like the Call of Duty's and the
impact they're having now and you know
the guys going in cleaning up the games
you know and getting the servers all
back up and running that's because of
what Phil did you know and there's
there's so much more and he even you
know he's acknowledged that there were
some things that he didn't like that
happened you know
um
lionhead Studios and the way they ended
up breaking them up he he realized that
was a mistake and and went forward from
there and uh I think that like I said he
he's about game preservation he's
getting good people in line because he
almost always when people praise Phil
yeah he praises the team
anything else from everybody else before
we move on with this uh Final Fantasy
stuff attic everybody's good yeah we're
we're we're fine okay cool no doubt soft
super chastics topics or just flying
yeah super chats hold on a second
we got
keep with the questions guys I'm writing
all these uh names down that people want
to see I gotta fuel we got a little bit
we got it a little bit okay we got
Stitch remember for 44 months Lord gold
is Sony on a panic mode now that the
last publisher to provide exclusives to
them publicly Embraces Xbox
is like you know take away you know what
your enemy strength is you know to kind
of make it your weakness regardless if
it even if it's the worst case that it
doesn't go to an acquisition I will say
future the prospects of future uh Final
Fantasy games being exclusive I no
longer you know that missing the
platform I think has lesson we got we
could at least I think agree that on a
very minimum level there's definitely
better hope than there was this time
last week yesterday definitely increase
the probability
one game is better than zero games let
me tell you this
when I speak it into existence be fifth
system I still think you go ahead of
yourself but I think you I hope you're
right I don't want you to stop against
pause
he want to do that one chip challenge
after seeing uh hoggy is seeing Jazz
after seeing uh guys do it and giving me
flashbacks so when I did it I could
never in good conscience say yo do a
chip over some video game crap hell you
you could ask hog I told him if you lost
that I wasn't gonna make bro take that
show yeah so I mean look the the bended
knee still stands it's just the the
reward or whatever
[Music]
Edwin Garcia five dollar Super Chat
resistance ratchet Infamous to name a
few work that were invented before Sony
acquired them I don't agree with Colin
about Xbox lacking art Xbox needs a
chance
okay
Raiden blade five pound Super Chat the
jftc and judge Jacqueline for pointing
the finger at Sony and ff16 inclusives
blocking and Congress looking at jftc
Square Enix is like Sega is in money
okay okay
there we go this is what we said that
fell through Cog on the table wow
so we got the same record five dollars
in the chat the King's Point about the
ABK deal being done Sarah Bond shared a
tweet from Activision she never did that
before
then we have our rice our REI
reis05 five pound super chat soon we
will hear Square Enix Xbox Studio
presents World exclusive
or something like that I can't wait till
I yell out at the Tokyo game show fresh
show free
oh
yeah Saul wants to Reign me in because
you know my biggest win is about to show
up yeah
I don't I don't like you we're taking
L's off of being a bad winner
I for one
if King is right about them buying
Square Enix you can have his knees back
yeah because at that point
you know the APK thing was one thing was
solved because it was actually a company
that you know not realistically we would
think they would see but you could
understand how that kind of conversation
happened but Square Enix
it kind of remind me like I told you
recipes this kind of make me think we
need a we need to tap his phones there's
some embezzles
we want to make excuses
bro he's got a direct line to you guys
he's well funded y'all
well funded very
[Music]
as I understand it from court documents
it was Zen xenomax or Square ff16 going
places inclusive or Star field Xbox
couldn't lose Starfield so they acquired
Zenni um
um then we have Spartan 6612 which web
Dave is a fan for Final Fantasy games
what's his opinion I think they gave his
a baby and yeah I love it yep that was
before he went yeah and then he gave his
opinion on the uh on Phil's regime
we have Lord Metroid two dollars Cog
show your more the sija techniques to
stop whoa I don't need to see no no
blood sausage techniques we're good
we're good we're good I trust my brother
has things under control
we are caught up all right so if this is
your topic set it up and then um what
you call it all day we gotta hit him up
with you because I know he's on limited
time yes sir so yeah earlier in the week
of ver uh report from VGC indicated that
the planned sequel to ubisoft's
Immortals Phoenix Rising had been
canceled uh in response to this you'll
be uh said and I quote they are
reallocating some creative teams and
resources within the Quebec Studio as
part of our Global strategy we are
redirecting and reallocating some
creative teams and resources within the
Quebec Studio to other unannounced
projects the expertise and Technologies
these teams develop will serve as an
accelerator for the development of these
key projects focused on our biggest
brands we have nothing further to share
at this time
um so yeah so basically this team which
is the same team that made AC Odyssey uh
was working on a sequel to Immortals
which honestly was received pretty
favorably overall yeah it seemed like it
was a something of a departure from
Assassin's Creed it was a a well-wanted
departure we've always wanted something
a little bit different a little bit
different right so uh people were
excited for what a potential sequel
could bring to the table and now it
seems that that has been undone so my
thinking on this is that you'll be
thinking right now is like unless it's
Assassin's Creed we're not really caring
about single player games unless it's AC
Assassin's Creed and everything that
they seem to be that seems to be in a
pipeline is falling through in favor and
I can almost guarantee you that one of
these projects that they're reallocating
uh at least one of these projects
they're reallocating resources to is
probably some sort of service based game
because that is kind of that that's
their game right now
um so I just want to know what y'all
think of this because this sucks this
absolutely sucks and to me listen 10
years ago I would have told you give me
all the Assassin's Creed you can I love
Assassin's Creed but I burnt out on it
to be honest with you man I got I got 20
hours into Valhalla and I'm like this is
too much man I didn't even hit 20 hours
it's crazy and the prospect of going
back to a game like Mirage is exciting
to me right but at the same time I kind
of do feel I'm worried that when I play
that game it's going gonna be like oh
they just went back to Brotherhood and
gave us that and didn't improve upon it
in any way shape or form so it kind of
leads back to this this sort of idea
that Ubisoft is bereft of creativity at
this point and they just trying to catch
waves and catch them very late and this
just feels like the the latest example
of that where it's like this they could
have taken this and when you when you
see what they wanted to do with the
series they were going to go into some
really weird like different mythologies
that we haven't even really you know
talked about and it wasn't gonna just be
this sort of this this the Greek
mythology and stuff like that so it to
me it's it's an opportunity lost where
we're probably going to get something
we're not super excited about some kind
of service based game multiplayer thing
um the other stuff that they have in the
pipeline that we know is supposed to be
single player Beyond Good and Evil hello
where are you
um I don't know what's going on I don't
know what's going on is I don't really I
don't know that that's for me so it
really is just Assassin's Creed I don't
see them going back to watch dogs
ever if maybe not for a long while maybe
ever
um and I don't I you know and Splinter
cells Splinter cells a little while away
but it's I'm telling you right now
Splinter Cell
the expectations for Splinter Cell I
think internally or super high and if
they don't meet that expectation we're
getting a one and done and that's it so
uh it's it's it to me I'm not liking
what ubee's doing right now I'm really
not so I just want to see where you guys
are with this let's give well let's get
web Dave well respect this time what's
your feeling about uh you know he
resolves Direction you know going
forward and obviously that cancellation
like solve was talking about
well the the game like the original game
that came out was was good worth playing
it was fun it was a different direction
I enjoyed it
um I think that they will be making a
mistake if they don't go back to it
because it was well received
um you know was it the best game ever no
but it gave good content and gave them
more of a diverse you know I guess as
far as the different platforms and the
different types of games they were
putting out uh it opened that up a
little bit but I one thousand percent
agree that they
cannot mess up
I cannot mess that up at all I agree I
agree it's uh it's uh so so if if
resources you know go to to whatever
they need to get to two that's good
but don't cancel Splinter Cell For the
Love of jeez that would be bad that's a
worry too man I ain't even think
honestly wasn't worried about that but
you just I don't know man I don't know
it's scary that's scary Microsoft needs
to plant a bag on them for that game to
for some extensive exclusive lockdown
but maybe like a you know hey you put
this in a game pass and and you can put
it on other platforms but there's a big
bag of money because we liked having it
as you know for a long time Splinter
Cell was Xbox oh yeah period oh yeah but
but and I don't I'm not privy to talk
about this in any sort of detail but it
kind of feels like the it kind of feels
like the powers that be feel like
Splinter Cell is an old thing
I don't know why because it's it's it's
okay as a pure stealth game you don't
see pure stealth games anymore right it
has to be it has to be an action
component to it but I think Splinter
Cell Blacklist shows you you can do both
you can give players both options and
they're going to play however they want
or a combination of the two and that'll
give you a great action game that's a
great point I don't I don't I kind of
don't see it I don't see that thinking
where it's like this is so old we can't
bring it we can't bring It Forward in in
a way that modern audiences care about
it that's very weird to me that thinking
especially with something like that when
you think about third person action
games and and what Splinter Cell will
bring to the table Espionage spies like
that it's just weird to me that you look
at them like now modern audiences
wouldn't Vibe with that it's very weird
so I to me I I feel like the powers that
be think of it that way where which is
why internally I think
the numbers for them have to be super
high they're putting this very high
threshold on it so almost kind of
wishing it doesn't make it so that they
don't have to go back to it again
because I if they had their choice I
think internally and I'm not I don't
mean the devs the people that love
Splinter cells that are working on it I
just mean the powers that be at UB
internally I would I honestly I think if
they could turn that into some service
based game and be done with a single
player aspect of it they'll be happy
with that and that's a sad thing to
think about yeah shout out to Tom
Henderson in the chat he's saying they
are not going to cancel spin to sell
smiley face thank you thank you thank
you Tom thank you no doubt Lord attic
what's your thoughts on this Assassin's
Creed thing I know you care about
Assassin's Creed very being dear IOP
Loki was founded between Assassin's
Creed and Destiny
yeah I think it's just one of those
things I think games as a service has in
a lot of ways you know shifted the
industry in a really bad place
companies now because of
microtransactions throughout the years
their profits have been fluffed so much
now if a game doesn't make that kind of
money they don't want to even even
remotely try it
unfortunately that's just how the
industry is going to go you know I
actually really enjoyed Immortals I
played it reviewed it it was a fun game
I remember like the little thing where
you fight the uh the heroes throughout
time it was in a very enjoyable
experience and I I hate that the sequel
was canceled and you know all I know is
Ubisoft keep this up they might end up
getting bought by Microsoft
so it's just it's sad man it's sad
hopefully though like Dave said that
we'll you know
get back together in the future and
realize they have made a mistake and
restart the development but I I highly
doubt that it's so funny how and anytime
a company is down now you're like hold
up
it's still sniffing around the corner
what's that gym that emoji for that dude
he got the heads by the tree oh you're
here I want to do it with the yellow
spices
it's like it's like Ubisoft King they
said they're talking in the boardroom
they're like what's all the things we
can do to get by by Microsoft
how can I help you help me like who's
got a rich scandal going on
anybody got any Bobby coltic stuff no
it's like it's it's like there's we're
not doing AV embezzlement but can we I
mean listen I feel like every company
has that person it's like your job is to
dig dirt
[Laughter]
you know Ubisoft Direction single player
games got canceled Assassin's Creed
Focus
well
when when in doubt you gotta uh go back
to what got you to to your Healthy
Heights and as much as y'all want to
hate on Assassin's Creed when that hit
it transformed Ubisoft yeah Ubisoft
turned into a conglomerate that was able
to push story driven
narrative games into a different area
and then they came out with a formula
that you can add a battle pass to a
story driven game that engaged
the the the the consumer in a matter of
you can buy this you can do that it
turned it into a live service game
without being a live service game right
and the reoccurring Revenue that they
were receiving from these games that was
Assassin Creed based at first
um showed them that there's there's this
gold in them dark Hills but
funny enough they saw a breath of the
wild and said
yo and yo that's different what what can
we come up with and you know one of the
teams like yo we got this game that's
sorta in the vein like that but it has
better combat it has this it has that yo
work on that let's see what you come up
with and then the Mortal Phoenix Rising
I mean that was a really good looking
game really good playing game very good
story and it had a place to go what I
felt that it was a little bit short in
where it launched that it should have
launched in a service right I think
single player games on new IPS should
launching a service that has a base of
over 35 million plus who does that oh
Game Pass
um but do that and and you can get eyes
on that game and then you can actually
give your game an opportunity to succeed
now as far as
um them putting all their stuff into
Assassin Creed please do please
Revitalize Assassin's Creed because it
was a time where I got fatigued off an
Assassin's Creed and then I saw
Assassin's Creed Origins and I'm a huge
Egyptian fan you know my religion is
based in that so
that game was outstanding and it
launched with hardware for the home that
took advantage of it so it had a double
type of adrenaline boost for that game
that game within itself was uniquely
positioned to Garner interest and from
there you got Odyssey and you got um the
next one on Valhalla and um I haven't
got a chance to play Valhalla yet but I
understand it's a huge undertaking when
you start playing these Ubisoft games I
know this I know the time that is
necessary to play these games is time
consuming is like a game of service oh
yeah but Splinter Cell
I don't think that they have to they
they have internal uh thoughts to saying
that it has to reach a certain thing I
think that internal pressure is put on
by the teams and know how much Splinter
Cell means to the Ubisoft DNA so I think
those internal
um pressures that that's put on is not
Financial in in basis it's actually
internally of what they what this
franchise means because if they do miss
then that's it right and I believe
that's that's really the case so
I also think
there's a group in there like the board
is like okay good y'all can do the story
John okay we got that I was joined with
spy and mercs how can we do spying mercs
in this day and age that can get at
least five to six people in on each team
says 10 people playing
um so we can get this reoccurring
Revenue going up you you want to make
your game we cool with that but we need
return on investment and we need a quick
turnaround so how can we get this game
of service because remember Ubisoft does
have a service Ubisoft plus they do have
a service
um how can we get this game to generate
income to fund other assassin Creeds
other games right and I think this game
is uniquely positioned to do so so you
can have a squad of mercs and you can
have a squad of uh spies and
you can work off that you can put skins
up in in different things oh dumb and
ninja costumes whatever it is you can
monetize and get that money together I
think this is what's happening with um
with that franchise right now so I do
believe that it hits I believe that the
story is going to be impeccable I
believe the the graphics is going to be
nuts but they do need to launch in a
service I don't care if it's PlayStation
service or Xbox service I prefer it to
be a Xbox game pass but if it doesn't
align up because Apple's box will be
Balling on all some of this Sony this
looks like something for you to jump
into and then it has that multiplayer
component which you should make free to
play and also have that battle pass in
them skins and stuff like that so you
can get that reoccurring Revenue I think
that happens there Ubisoft is really
good I'm looking forward for the
Assassin's Creed I'm not upset with what
they're doing and how they're pivoting
when you do have to Pivot pivot to your
strips because that ensures some form of
Victory when you're taking losses so if
they had a 60 40 loss right now you
might switching to Assassin's Creed
putting all your eggs in one basket to
ensure that it must be a hit because I
don't want a mid Assassin's Creed to
come out I want that serious Assassin's
Creed to come out so you can turn it
from a 60 40 deficit to a 60 40 positive
and I think that can happen
look no too much to add you guys pretty
much nail a lot of the points I was
going to say
um I just think they are going through a
transitionary period where you know they
they really were struggling and
um I do feel like it's almost like a
consolidation of let's get back to what
actually makes the most money and that's
Assassin's Creed you know so at the end
of the day Assassin's Creed is the
breadwinner that's what transformed them
you know I do kind of empathize with
solve in the sense that we've known them
to be this super creative company that
you know sometimes would take these
risks and early you'll be soft at one
point it was the tops in the game like
like everything they touch was gold I
think they just went through a streak of
just being on fire and then Assassin's
Creed hit and then boom it's like okay
we got something then to me they kind of
got a little EA in them and they started
to oh let's mad in this you know what
I'm saying unless every year we're gonna
keep giving you assassins created and I
think the fan base got eventually burned
doubt as great as it is right and and
like you said you know you can live in
these worlds the Assassin's Creed game
right now Valhalla is insane like you
can live in that world it's just where I
fell out of favor for personally because
it wasn't Assassin's Creed anymore to me
yep like this is action adventure you
know RPG RPG a thousand icons on the
screen just vomit on the screen and just
play all day all right fine that's great
for you me I'm the guy that like being
in Jerusalem through the crowd you know
American murder plot plot you have to
get the investigations up before you
could just do a direct at the Target
like I'm from the real Assassin's Creed
and and the American murder that that's
what I like so that's when they really
felt I loved me and I'm like this
holiday is great as it is I and odyssey
is great as it is what's the one with
the um Roman Spartan ones is that
Odyssey
yeah like you know look those are great
games I don't want me to spell it's just
that they're not this the the Ubisoft of
assassin creed that I know them to be
the only thing that I do like is even
though they are doubling down on
Assassin's Creed now I guess it's Mirage
which is going to be I think more of the
stealth Focus right they're giving you
they're giving you Assassin's Creed
every year again now but they're just
changing up the type of Assassin's Creed
it is year to year right so yeah it's
like they break it down in two Styles
now you know what I'm saying so yeah you
know for the the current base that has
been you know loving the action
adventure kind of stuff they're gonna
have that and then this one is kind of
for me I want to see and then obviously
they're going to Japan I did hear rumors
of uh um African Samurai possibly yes
did hit rumors we got to see you know
because as if they're going if they base
it on what's my man yeah yeah you know
who was bait there was a real yeah a lot
of people a lot of people don't know
that so I'm curious if they go that
route I heard the rumor is one you know
it might be two characters one
traditional samurai the other one a
Shinobi we'll see where they go I'm
curious crazy that would be crazy I'm
pulling for them
yeah I was listening while I was in the
other room uh they're doing kind of like
what Sega is doing with the Yakuza
franchise we're gonna we're gonna
double the work for everyone because we
know we can make the money on the long
end and we can
not only get people into a newer
franchise we can also provide the
experience that our older franchise love
yeah look you know they're they're going
through what they're going through and I
will say this Lord actually this is
probably the one though I do not want
for acquisition and I'd be yourself I've
had this conversation I'll you'll be I
love you but
you're too big and I don't feel they
offer they wouldn't offer Microsoft
anything
don't say different Assassin's Creed is
huge but I'm just saying it's just like
I feel like even square and Sega and the
others have more to offer in the mobile
right to help Xbox's long-term thing you
know I mean and they got their own
service today I think I think Square
offers more when it comes to a diverse
portfolio yeah because those mobile
games those are some of the best looking
games yeah yeah it doesn't uh didn't
Ubisoft have like a huge staff I mean
like more employees yes than what the
currently is at
um Microsoft after the ABK deal yeah the
good thing is you would ever pick up you
if you saw could never have to make
another game as a service ever oh they
got that down they'll definitely yeah
that's all I got in the interesting time
you want to um I'm sorry yourself you
mentioned yes okay um yes so Netflix has
a has a series on him I didn't even know
that I had no idea yeah that would I
mean mean for me that would be awesome I
think it's one thing that Assassin's
Creed does super super well is just the
historical song Oh nobody beats them on
that facts facts yeah they're historic
photographic uh and then of the area and
the time period they do the research
like you can never take that from
Ubisoft like they I will always bend in
the beginning we was at um a Fan Fest
when we was talking to the developer oh
yeah no he was explaining to me uh that
they was actually on site taking
pictures of pyramids uh doing all the
stuff it was incredible the knowledge
that they had all right I really enjoyed
Odyssey yes uh but you know that that's
a very good RPG signed an Assassin's
Creed game yeah that's how I feel that's
literally how I feel so look um solve
how the super chats go away yeah just
one Super Chat Robert Kelly Two Dollar
Super Chat crash Spyro banjo Sonic and
Rayman damn
everybody's mascot after the ABK deals
done Microsoft new needs to look into
making their own Super Smash Brothers
so many popular IPS yeah I'm a cart
racer
little car racer that'd be good too I'm
upset you know what would be lit if they
if they approached Nintendo it was like
let's make a Super Smash Bros for Xbox
of Xbox characters and this cross Play
Between the Nintendo characters it's the
same game but we only have access to
Xbox characters and they lay back as
Nintendo cave we'll see the last time
they went and never win the 10 that they
got they got laughed out the room so
it's a long time ago
they said it's like not fam we good so
that was that oh another one also uh we
got Necromancer zail five dollars to be
chat buying Ubisoft now is throwing
money away they are an IP by oh that's
how I feel bro it's true specific IP for
sure yeah I want money
Ubisoft has so many people because they
have so many games as a service no doubt
all right just got to be respect uh Lord
Webb Dave how we doing sir as I know
this is the last time it's five o'clock
yeah yeah
stuff you have to do should we give you
your outro your flowers down sir that
would that would that would it would be
gracious yes if I could I I hate to do
it and I'm so sorry bro bro you rocked
out
see not everyone's expected to to go
through the marathon exactly look man I
want to give you your flowers first of
all long overdue love that she had each
of us individually on your platform and
outbreak Gamers and hearing our story
and you know just to hear that you know
there's other people Gamers like that
kind of going through the same
experiences we have I love what you do
for the community it's it's very very
Spotlight a lot of people the big the
small and then also I just love that
your contact is also very your
background you don't say as far as Pop
Culture entertainment Rock everything
man love what you're doing in the
community and definitely touched us that
you know you do value what IOP brings
and that meant a lot as well so tell the
fine people where they can find you what
you got going on sir man uh wow this has
been awesome
um to you know if you were like check
mark off of the things that you you know
hope that you could do someday this was
one of them so thank you so much uh all
of you uh like I said you're all so
gracious to be interviewed and uh and
not only that but it was it was the when
we got into talking you know I think
some people even hesitate they're not
really sure where the conversation is
going to go and then when we get
comfortable and we get talking and it's
just one-on-one you know like uh Lord
Sovereign men his conversation you know
it got kind of personal in some parts to
different directions but I never I never
you know but I even told him it's like
you know if we don't we don't want to go
this way we won't and he was he jumped
in and we had a great time and that's
and that's the thing uh and that lets
people know more about the the amazing
content providers that you guys are and
and I appreciate each and every one of
you and I'm I don't mean that and one of
these days I'm gonna I'm gonna talk to
addict about some of his mind tricks
that he does to get some guests on
because there's a few guests
he is amazing he shoots his shot and
sometimes if you front on me like all
right I'm I'm coming I'm gonna spin the
block with you yeah like like he don't
play like he listen that he's a shooter
just like everybody like he don't play
man so salute you yeah and I love it and
I do and I love each and every one of
you so thank you so much for letting me
be here
um Tonight
Show coming up in a couple hours
um uh and and I know that sounds sounds
weird but I I definitely want to make
sure that when people are done here
um is going to be on so you can jump and
go see funds and the reason I say that
is not you know it's not my show no but
he's such a great content uh Creator and
it's such a great member of the
community I fully support him and then
of course when he you're done with his
show then come see us if you want to oh
you gotta we're going to be right there
is a season IOP game talk live and then
boom outbreak games which is a gaming
Council excuse me yeah that's okay yeah
yeah well it's you know it's a it's a
it's a full day on a Sunday
um and you know and for me it's kicking
off right with the with the with the
iron Lord so thank you all so much and
uh but uh but but The Tonight Show we're
gonna have heartbeat Johnny and and we
also got the fuzzy Bell over there fuzzy
uh and of course we're gonna be hitting
all the hot topics and getting crazy a
little spicy and uh and so it's gonna be
fun it's going to be great and um I I
can't thank you all enough for giving me
the time to be on here uh a true
blessing and thank you all so much I'm
gonna I'll bow gracefully and I'll shut
the hell up before you do before you do
it everybody got to give you give the
outro to you real quick addict uh you
want to say any followers to uh Mr Lord
web Dave yeah if you ever need any help
with anything like that feel free to
message me what I like about you is you
uh acknowledge to uh all the podcasts
and us too
so you know I have no problem giving you
uh my knowledge because you acknowledged
me yeah that's true yeah that's true
message me anytime you need no I
appreciate that I won't beat you but
what I promise but there may be one or
two but like hey do you have a way to
get a hold of this person because I
didn't find any other resources to get a
hold of them so thank you sir I
appreciate that man Lord solve I'll
forgive our web to give his flowers
before he heads out yeah brother you
know I told you when we sat down to talk
I was like you have that voice that that
calming sort of voice
we could say like our whole life story
exactly
that is a perfect comparison yes you
guys and there's a genuine sort of love
for what the story that's being told
right and uh that that not everybody
could do that man not everyone do that
so again always happy to sit down I know
we talked about trying to figure out how
to get on your show uh on a Sunday after
our show so I'll figure that out I'll
figure it out at some point but thanks
for coming through man I I love the
history obviously someone in such a
shared history with us it's always fun
to talk about that stuff because uh you
know the young guys that don't don't
understand that
and we've been through it too yeah
thank you sir thank you so much
Lord web Dave off
my dude um from one apex predator
I love that
um I respect you I respect your game in
history uh I learned a lot of stuff
about you today I mean I mean I was on
your show and we talked but that was
about me and I'm so happy that I got a
chance to get into uh what make web Dave
Tech you know um I knew about the the
radio show but what I didn't know was
your gaming history and this is the
reason why iron Lords do this uh to to
get into the history because y'all did
not know that y'all was walking around
with an apex predator
you're not talking your platinums and
y'all yo we put some respect on web
Dave's name man like don't ever come at
him he's not the dude that you could
talk to because he looks at you like
yeah you cute
that's cute I love everything you do I
love the fact that you're soft-spoken
you have a art style within yourself
where it's comfortable to talk to you
um and that's why when you reached out
to me we work on whatever we can work on
because uh you are super humble you are
a great dude to this community and like
I said whatever you ever need from me I
will definitely
go all out of my way to make sure that
can happen because I respect you and you
know what I knew like when you look into
a kilos from one killer to the next
you look into that kill eyes you realize
who it was like and we you didn't have
to speak it we just understood it so I
respect you brother thank you so much
and and I had a great time you know
learning your history today so can't
wait to watch the gaming Council later
absolutely thank you sir appreciate it
Legend web Dave outbreak Graves we put
the information in chat go subscribe to
this channel go check them out excellent
content and a good dude in our community
salute enjoy your day brother we
definitely try to pop him you know and
when you get you get your show rolling
later on today thanks guys I really
appreciate each and every one of you
have a great show and uh come on you
guys can go to six seven hours right now
[Music]
and on that note
[Laughter]
love you guys thank you so much Dell and
this is the final topic unless we got
any Super Chat what's up popular demand
yes I'm gonna just do it one time and
that's all oh
[Music]
all right cool last one this is King's
topic
of course of course uh ratcheting I'm
okay with this topic though are you okay
with it Ratchet and Clank performance on
uh PC hard drive is a point of
discussion uh I don't really have an
article in conjunction with it just that
obviously it went out on PC that there's
been a lot of discussion in reference to
the if it was only possible on the SSD
conversations by Insomniac so it looks
like digital Foundry did do a comparison
it refers to hard drives where they did
show or one of the uh you know hard
drive that it was you know not
functional now we've had other people
come out to make tests whether on
standard HD uh drives that it can be
functional off some have been varying
where they show the game still running
uh through the riffs of some of the more
difficult sections so that I get started
a discussion shout out to oh no it's
Alex shout out to uh for taking place
they both have videos I guess showing
you know with a 17 7 200 RPM and a 5400
RPM what the differences are and if it
could run or not
the results were interesting so King
this is your topic I don't I I think I
know where you're going with this but uh
yeah how do you feel about the real
world performance of ratchety clack PC
or basic standard hard drives
the moment King saw that this is what
happened
you triggered my trap card so what we do
who are you calling that what's going on
yo bro what's up with the homie brat
what's going on ah Brad was a cool dude
you don't remember yeah that's the only
though on the PlayStation 5 SSD like
man listen when they when when the money
Get Low
they're gonna point that over shout out
to my love my heart Nexus
that did The Impossible your dream The
Impossible Dream
you you crushed Pony Dreams by reaching
the goals
you those thought she was special
a regular
hard drive no no I'm in regular hard
drive and say hey yo yo what's up they
took a Volvo
Lamborghini again
the Volvo was just two seconds behind
yo you don't look prettier you know it
shows so much it shows so much that is
wrong with your mentality was sweet I
told you on the SSD was just talk bro
there was just something to hike the
price up on you
yeah
and I shout out to digital Foundry did
you found you try their best to make
your look better
because they had it on PS4 specs yeah
they put a laptop hard drive and then
trying to run into that PlayStation 4
specs nah gee shout out to oh no it's
Alex and for taking a place
this is why we have independent Auditors
oh man
somebody that's not brought and paid for
oh I don't do that don't do that that's
the code
come on
our way we wasn't saying that it is but
the numbers is going that way so much
yo shout out to the independent
fact Checkers the fact check the
situation all right yo I knew this day
was coming
I knew that y'all was gonna get this
work
I just laid in the cut and just waited
and everything that y'all talk about the
next thing for y'all and y'all know when
I speak it it happens that's Spider-Man
too
when it don't perform how it's supposed
to perform
in numbers wise it's gonna end up on
that PlayStation 4.
and all that switching and stuff that
y'all talk about could only be done by
the SSG
dude yo the PlayStation 4 Pro gonna be
like whatever B
a shout out to y'all for believing the
hype and I knew it was just hype I love
you guys equally because y'all give me
entertainment every day all right but
all right but first let's get at it
what's the break news and then I got
asking it's not like big big breaking
news but apparently the the European uh
agency something over here said that EU
yeah I don't know so they said that with
70 to 80 of Game Pass subscriptions are
ultimate yeah oh wow that's crazy you're
not like that narrative says that
everyone's on the dollar deal
you know all right so all right okay
before we open this up I do got to ask
you okay so the the the point of
contention right now is did Insomniac
you know Sony marketing live that it
could only be run on the yeah
it ain't nowhere around it y'all can sit
there and try to I don't know where they
said I saw it I heard it through the
power of the SSD you're able to
transverse worlds absolutely no problem
it's like
magically right there I have recorded
for somebody to read cool yeah go read
the quote all right so let's read the
quote all right so basically I'm ready
I'm ready yeah hey sorry X Marcus Smith
creative director on the game explain
how this new feature was only made
possible with PlayStation 5 solid state
drive in this video he said ratchet
Clank Rift apart is a game that utilizes
dimensions and dimensional riffs and
that would not have been possible
without the solid state drive of the
PlayStation 5. explain Smith
um obviously impossible means you can't
really do it you're doing any other SSB
anybody told me it was impossible I
ain't gonna try to attempt it but
make the jump I'm like oh it's possible
he said the SSD is screamingly fast it
allows us to build worlds and project
players from one place to another at
near instantaneous speeds so I think
that's the thing that people here issue
is so people some people say yeah they
didn't lie because look it's not
possible on PlayStation 4 or Playstation
4. but they could they did it did when
the digital flasher when that one that
he was hung up for man okay PS4 you want
to put a PS4 spec but um the bottom line
is the SSD is not necessary in that
space like that let's let's get down to
the Crux of it okay don't try to play
semantics with me don't try to take a
goal post and throw a goal post over
here not not you I'm just talking about
these dudes out here that's trying to
move the goal post this is where I take
it from jokes to being looking at you in
your eyes because you disillusional boy
I'm gonna let y'all know right now stop
playing with me you guys your SSD is not
what you thought it was and it hasn't
shown it yet so maybe that game from
Quantum era can show you the SSD is four
times as fast
yo I just
honor everything and then when we tear
it down and throw it in the bushes they
move the goal post and step over like
you're going to get wet it's raining
outside just take the wetness spot the
spot talking about all that that ain't
it though because remember King what I
had said was said yeah stop it man it's
a l for you and y'all have been doing
nothing but taking else and you know
what I know when the PlayStation dude
has taken the L so hard and it hurts so
bad they do the same thing out there all
all PlayStation oh they pull red fall
out their butt
but red
the first person to bring up redfall
look redfall was underwhelming to a lot
of people I didn't particularly enjoy to
actually uninstalled it but like we got
to stop using that as a de factor I I do
think that that's an outliner that's not
let me ask you a question addict because
I think you can answer this for me and I
just want to ask attic this question
what came first red foil for focus
and
you're smoking thank you enough said
okay
back to you the kids wanted the
never-ending ratcheting like topic we
finally we have finally closed the door
on that and the reason why I had the Hat
on was because all you dudes got hayachi
face right so as you can see the tearing
haji's eye this is you with this so when
you saw it already know that HD 7200
that's what you get killed yo I've ran
to the TV right because it was like
digital foundries up and I saw it on my
phone I said no no no no no no no no no
I gotta sit down on the couch for this
because if they prove me wrong they're
coming for me so I gotta be ready and
I'm watching and I'm watching as any
general should
my hands was getting sweaty I'm sitting
there like
and it was like yeah it's possible with
a delay got him
got him that's
right got him yeah and then I saw
fatigue plays video I was like it's over
you know what's funny King I always uh
you know when me and dirty are doing the
attic show I'm always saying because
dirt you know he he's all about the we
we only let people in here that's gonna
Vibe with us we ain't about that that
PlayStation fan boy in the Chester I was
like I was like IOP the front line I was
like well our second streak of Arab bone
arrow people that's dirt he's
controlling that every time someone
tries to hit our flank dirt got one of
his people with an arrow straight going
at them and we got Specialists like oh
no it's Alex and fatega y'all better
watch out man they're The Mercenaries we
hire from a time to time
addict any thoughts on you now PC
Mastery showed me your build guy
um look dude do I yeah do I think that
the
the particular developer
try to lie on this I don't I think he
was just saying stuff people say stuff
he wasn't thinking what he was saying I
don't think he meant this can't be done
on PC I think he meant this can't be
done on Playstation 4. because they
don't have the SSD that's in the PS5 but
it doesn't matter what you intend on
people it matters how people take that
information and especially that's why PR
exists they want to make sure that you
say things in a way that the public
can't you know take in a different way
than you actually intend and it's it's
on him he should have been a lot better
or uh saying stuff now we got the
digital Foundry he quote tweeted digital
family tree said see I told you uh we
didn't lie he doubled down like he ain't
lying yeah I think that's just one of
those things it's like I'm finding the
little bit of a straw that makes me
right see I told you
it's like nah like you know he should
have just left himself stay in The Ether
talking to whoever he was talking to you
know it it looks bad for PlayStation
because like you have a developer coming
out there saying that this is only
possible on the PlayStation 5 SSD I
personally don't think he was talking
about
the the custom SSD and the PlayStation 5
I think you just talked about they're
literally SSD and the PlayStation 5 but
regardless how I interpret it homeboy
out there jumping off skyscrapers if no
info so you know let him Jump Man let
him jump because they ain't a parachute
at the bottom here man we we don't
believe in that you jump you jump no
preservation of human life okay oh we're
gonna move on
serve PC Master faces old what are your
thoughts on all of this
okay this is the this is what happens
when any of us listen to marketing speak
right these are the pitfalls because I
don't know about you but on my series X
I ain't seen a whole lot of FS FSR
you ready for your machine to start
learning yeah exactly you know short of
scorn I don't know anybody else that's
really rocking it like that and it's
like and to me when you when you talk
about the console early on before it
comes out and you put all these
buzzwords out there right
you put all these buzzwords out there to
me every time you have you sh every time
a game comes out that's utilizing that
stuff I would think you bring that to
the Forefront hey this game is utilizing
FSR 2.0 whatever and none of that has
happened none of this happened if it if
not for digital Foundry and these other
sort of uh YouTube channels that are
specialized in the technical aspects of
you know these games we wouldn't know so
that when I say scorn scorn was one of
the first ones I guess using 2.0 oh wow
yeah
um I don't remember scoring ran at 60 on
the series X I don't I don't recall
super slow
we wouldn't know yeah so it's one of
those things like
things like that marks are only talking
about your ears and things like this you
always got a ticket with a great assault
because you know it's not quite true and
this is a perfect example of it where
it's like yeah in this specific scenario
with these specific switches turned on
it don't work it'll work I told y'all
um but the fact of the matter is you can
play for this game from stem to stern
with a regular ass hard drive
it it kind of makes it untrue so I would
say as informed Gamers let's just keep
ourselves informed and not get too hyped
by what we hear about things because
like I said I'm still waiting for this
FSR 2.0 3.0 godsend is going to make
that should theoretically have made
Starfield 60 FPS on series X things like
that so again I it's just funny to be
because it all comes to fruition and we
always talk about the OR at the at the
start of every generation we go back and
think oh yeah all the excitement we have
for the secrets yes Ram of all of these
different platforms foreign
I was like you know we just we always
fall for the banana and tailpipe every
time every time we're gonna do it again
to the Next Generation oh my God
let us let us not forget that the Box on
the PlayStation 5 says 8K ah man listen
I'm sorry that's it bad that's it it's
just funny to me um this is bound to
happen yeah that's about listen you know
you know we'll always be there um In
fairness you know they when they ran it
on that PS4 spec I hate when he says
corporate balance balance come out for a
little bit look when they try to run
that joint with that 5400.
yo that joint was not like it was broke
in the corner where they're saying
that's not yeah that is so in in that
sense then yes it would have been that
but the problem I think when people have
issue is that what king is saying when
you see the 7200 hard drive first of all
anything this one to me is still
marketing speak regardless
Amy SSD that runs the game that's not a
PlayStation 5 spec it's still denounces
that marketing speed because it was it
was the way it was explained was like it
can only be done now again that's how
you interpret it right now you can
interpret it from a console perspective
and say yo they didn't lie because yo
PlayStation 4 can't run that and because
of this you're showing the jump for PS4
to PS5 I think that's fair but what I
also think is fair there was a lot of
the fan base that was running down on
the PC Community remember that song yeah
they were running down on the PC
Community picking fights who nobody
asked for it's like bro you can't go to
that dude and say we're stronger than
you because you're set at your when you
did was it development with three or
four year old you know Parts internally
where the PC is always involved so the
PC dude gonna put a receipt word oh yeah
yeah okay y'all [__] that nobody can't
[__] that right so we gonna take you to
the gym when your part come over over
here and they took them to the gym and
that's just the funny thing is it
remember back then there was no talk on
PC ports on Playstation games yeah right
so this is this is a fight that they
they could throw that out there and not
have no point in comparison like yeah
this will never get proven wrong right
they thought it would never
at the time the talk was PC ports will
never happen so not only did the PC Port
happened now the PC Community gets to
say oh really you you lifted this this
was your this is your personal best one
on the bench right we gonna get our
little dude that at you over here that
dope got all if I use it all that you
got and he could still lift that and
that's what happened in my opinion so I
do understand that's what it is so look
welcome to speak you know like soft said
you know banana type stuff I think they
did get it Saudi definitely utilized
this to their advantage to make the the
system in the game watch the game is
phenomenal it's a great game but I did
see it running on a 7200 RPM hard drive
and it was pretty much imperceptible as
far as like maybe a slight like even the
most smallest of hitch and I'll just
like oh but everything else and I shout
out to Alex I saw him he was testing
everything he had all this stuff
when they have no affiliation to do yeah
PC and again in in defense of them you
know they're PC guys first right so when
you come for the PC Community they're
going to put it through its Paces
they're gonna see everything what you
said if it's due and that's where
they're gonna pop off so look it's funny
to me it's hilarious you know I thought
this was a funny topic a cake brought
back because I knew he was going to do
that I told you so here we go but here's
what it is it is what it is let's get up
out of here this is a long joint y'all
going like the Poo
um unless it's only super chat so we do
the poll now so let me see yeah super
chats we just got let me see uh Robert
Kelly on Super Chat runs on PC then
ratchet can run on switch 480p
let's go baby
then let's put the crest in the chat for
Lord bronze 100 keeping it 100.
shout out to you thank you sir
that's it okay cool all right Paul is up
with the latest news regarding Final
Fantasy 14 coming to Xbox and the
potential of future Final Fantasy games
coming to Xbox platforms which do you
anticipate happening first
choices are a octopath traveler 2 coming
Xbox
B Final Fantasy 16 coming to Xbox
C Final Fantasy remake coming to Xbox or
D I don't care
Phil got his arm around your girl
and it's about to put a ring on it those
are the choices please
the book when it goes up on the ILP chat
salute to the amazing web Dave good to
have him man man I was long overdue band
was patient we finally made it happen
great story one of the hilarious once
you have kid impressed on that level of
your game history the man it was you
know a legend on that and uh yeah salute
salute let's do our outros uh Lord attic
where can Define people find what you
got going on sir
you can find me on Twitter at Lord It's
IOP you guys follow me on YouTube a
gaming addict I'm actually closing in on
5 000 Subs
cribe
I want to hit that before the end of the
year that would be nice so I'm gonna put
my uh my link in the chat you know some
of you haven't followed me up I'm pretty
much posting content every day besides
the weekends and sometimes I even do
something on the weekends so I
appreciate everyone coming through we
had up to like over a thousand people in
here hit that like button we we so close
to over a thousand likes oh yeah can we
please get over a thousand likes before
the end of the podcast I would
appreciate it if not it is what it is
but you know we we have some
some big
big plans in the next couple months
um I some of these things we've ever
done yeah obviously we're not gonna come
so giveaway that we got away yeah we
still got to do that yeah we still got
dinner yeah we'll we'll figure that out
I here's the thing
we had that console giveaway
at 15 000. and I know people's like man
you guys are like 18. I didn't expect to
almost hit nineteen thousand in a month
it's it's been it's been simply insane
so you know definitely hit that like
button uh
get on our patreon man me and King just
reacted to oh yeah we reacted to what
was that that was Darth Vader versus uh
uh Nobby yeah Darth Vader from Star Wars
versus Obito from Naruto we're gonna do
more of those reactions we react to
animes over there I've been recording me
watching um Twisted Metal I'm gonna put
those on there when I finish that uh you
know definitely go over there yeah to
ask questions that are on the show yeah
every time we answer the the questions
those come straight from our patreon so
you know you guys definitely get some
value out of that yeah you know I
appreciate everyone coming through it
was it was a really good show I'm gonna
put our patreon uh Link in the in the
chat too so definitely go over there and
uh sub to that no doubt salute salute
Lord solve good to have you back brother
good to see you up and well look like
your energetic self where can the five
people find you what you got going on
glad to be back thank you again thanks
once again to have everybody who kind of
reached out I appreciate it my brother's
here appreciate y'all looking out for me
King every single day calling me I
appreciate that brother calling me
no I mean it was so weird because I was
like you know we don't we don't talk
every day like that but he was like yo
but I will make sure you all right man I
mean let me pull you through this so I
appreciate it um and yeah uh hopefully
by this time next week I'll be telling
you that I finally beat Resident Evil 4
remake and got started on that Alan Wake
rebate because I want to get through
that before Alan Wake too so I really
want to do that uh yeah so hopefully
that's where I'll be at glad to be back
no doubt no doubt Lord King camera off
crowns on the cameras off the whole time
I'm so sorry yeah you good you're good I
couldn't find people find you what you
got going on
um man uh first I'm dealing with a whole
lot it's like a ton of range of emotions
bro like I mean that's that's really
kind of you know devastating because you
know you think about something and you
want to be a lady from one guy but man
I'm really devastated man if it's super
devastating to me I understand that the
whole town in Houston
right now but remember this the guy
already beat the greatest thing in life
and that was coming back from the car
you know um the fight of the of the
lifetime of
um this was a fight of uh Destiny and it
was it was great then they made it there
they made a boat money so shout out to
them web date to to actually look across
and to see uh apex predator that um
I I don't use these words lightly but
you know a a big Gia a stomp a a dude a
step a dude that's in that space like he
made it his business like he told you he
wasn't Rich he he downplaying that bro
I kept that pocket watching
yeah you you rich bro stop it you do
those things and to to have that rich
history and gaming it's very it's very
hard to find these individuals he's part
of the one percent and I love everything
that he talks about and everything in
his history and everything
um solve I'm so happy you're back yes
sir thank you my brother you add an
extra layer to reading super chats
um that I think this is the reason why
we flow so good when it comes to Super
chats
people want to hear how you interpret
their voice how you read Because when
they write things they write it in a way
that they know that you're going to yes
in that way oh yeah yeah if they throw a
little saucer there I would throw a
little salsa there too pause
that's that's though um patreon members
you hear me keep talking about the the
console giveaway console giveaway is
going to really be for patreon members
be honest with you
um because we got to narrow it down um
because I want to do a whole video thing
I want to do something that's going to
really highlight the giveaway to the the
patreon member and um we do r r with the
Lords that's on patreon attic and I do
reactions addict does uh reactions to
shows we're going to start doing
reactions to trailer so uh Ty and I are
um doing r r with the Lords and you know
attic is the the guy in the chair in the
background holding everything down
making everything happen and the the
show is moving along really well so if
you want to know how about Oppenheimer
or the Barbie movie
or the secret Wars uh go check that out
because the r r is their uh they're
public too so anyway you can watch those
so go so go check that out you don't
have to be a member of patreon go check
it out to see if you like it uh I'm
pretty sure that you will if you want my
take on the Barbie movie it will shock
you yeah
you saw it right good we'll talk about
that in the background uh y'all not
gonna get that for free go to patreon
but it's free on patreon
the reason why I'm probably a little bit
more introspective is because the movie
really hit in a space where the loss of
life is nothing to be played with and I
just noticed that watching that movie
the further you got away from the
creation of said bomb
the indifference to life yes
disgustingly on display and it sickened
me to my stomach to to see people have
that much indifference to something that
they had no direct contact in creating
and that is terrifyingly scary that that
permeates our existence as human beings
so I mean I think everybody should go
see the film The every actor that was in
that film gave a A plus performance and
if you can give an Oscar to the whole
cast I think this is the only movie I
can say in recent history that deserve
it every last person deserves an Oscar
in this film no doubt no doubt yeah I
gotta get your Blues right my Movie game
I'm so behind so much talk with the King
every
saturday.net they pulled up to so you
got to salute to support the team go uh
hit the website retweet the Articles
y'all if you go to the Lords of
gaming.net on Twitter account it really
really helps us get the visibility out
we independ we fully independent y'all
we independent you know what I'm saying
doing our thing and we want to put
Cheyenne on them I'm gonna put the
Twitter account of the law actually
that's the last word Lords of gaming.net
real quick go support the team man
because we got we got a hungry group
that really puts out high quality go
check that out go subscribe go share the
articles but that's all I got everybody
enjoying and Sunday anything else we got
forget about it
I'm going to send you guys over there to
fonts this show hasn't started yet it
starts in eight minutes
get some food get some drinks come back
and you know uh he's got he's always got
a pretty solid show and if you don't got
time at least hit that like button on
your way
exactly
we good everybody's good yeah we're good
all right enjoy your Sunday we catch
y'all
thank you
[Music]
foreign